This is Jocko podcast number one 67 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Beware of that trap.
Yeah,
choose dear Beowulf.
The better part.
Eternal rewards do not give way to pride for a brief while your strength is in
bloom.
Yeah,
but it fades quickly and soon there will follow illness or the sword to lay you
low or a sudden fire or surge of water or jabbing blade or javelin from the air
or repelling to age.
Your piercing I will dim and dark skin
and death will arrive.
Dear Warrior
to sweep you away
and that right there is some
timeless wisdom offered by the
the epic poem.
Beowulf.
Yeah.
The first poem in the English language,
of course it's old English,
which is mutually unintelligible from the modern English that we speak,
but it has some incredible translations if you want to read it.
I recommend the Seamus Haney version,
but regardless of the translation translation that you get,
the story remains.
It has do on the lessons,
lessons based on war
and leadership
and really human nature.
And we find these lessons over and over and over again throughout history and in
different cultures and in different wars.
And we all continue to learn,
okay,
every day from history and from each other.
And it certainly seems that there are some principles that are universal.
There are some underlying unifying theories that bind together then thread
through leadership and war and human nature.
And the more we experience in life,
the more clearly we can see the thread of these unifying theories.
I am tonight,
I happen to have on the podcast and individual with a lot of experience,
experience in war,
experience in leadership and experience in life.
And he also happens to be someone that I grew up with in the seal teams who is a
great friend and who just retired a couple days ago as a seal master chief,
my friend and my brother by the name of Jason Gardner.
Jason Jocko,
thanks for coming on math.
Hey,
I'm really excited to be here.
And,
um,
it's kind of cool because I know that you listen to the podcast and you were one
of the first guys that reached out to me.
I don't even know what number podcast it was,
but you reached out to me really early and said,
hey,
this is kick ass man,
keep doing it.
And then you know,
as the podcast kind of spread,
I started hearing from more guys but that was a pretty,
you were literally the first guy that reached out to me and said,
bro,
keep it going.
And I said,
cool Wilco.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And like iris is the one that said,
told me,
Hey Jocko has got a podcast.
And I'm like,
oh,
okay.
She goes,
you don't know how to listen to podcasts to you said no.
Gave her my phone.
She got it set up.
It was episode six and within a week and a half because of my commute,
I was caught up and then just dialed in from there on out and talking about it,
sharing it with a lot of other guys and it's been a huge help to me.
That's awesome.
And yeah,
if anyone hasn't put this together yet.
Uh,
this is iris and gardeners husband and Iris was on podcast number 70.
So if you want to listen to that,
you can hear us talk about you,
I guess indirectly because you were still active duty in the day,
so.
All right,
let's get to your story.
Let's talk about you.
Okay.
Where'd you grow up?
Uh,
I,
my dad was in the Marine Corps,
so we moved around a little bit,
kind of settled down,
up in San Clemente here in Orange County,
grew up up there,
uh,
swam,
played water polo,
did that through high school and then,
uh,
yeah,
I think I started doing a martial art card,
college of camp on one of the instructors was a team guy in Vietnam or dairy and
add it back in the day,
you know,
I had no one knew what seals were.
Yeah.
And then my parents had found out that,
that he was a COO and Vietnam and they're like,
oh,
you know,
this guy was a seal.
And I'm like,
well,
what is that?
And then they said,
these guys are awesome.
It's really hard training their water warriors,
which was super appealing growing up at the beach and water polo and swimming.
So then I just latched onto that and that's what what I got after and enlisted
right out of after high school.
So it was your dad,
was your dad kind of like the stereotypical marine that was just like,
oh no,
like acting like a drill.
Started charging.
I know my dad,
my dad was super laid back easy.
It's an easy going,
good guy.
And he was a Jag officer in the Marine Corps,
so he was like,
uh,
an attorney.
Um,
but,
but not definitely not your stereotypical marina.
And at one point I was thinking about going in the Marine Corps and he talked me
out of it.
I don't do it,
don't do it.
And he's like,
Hey,
the navy,
the seal teams is closed loops.
Or You could go to recon,
Ben,
at the time it wasn't closed loops.
So you'd go in and out,
in and out.
He goes,
you don't want to do that.
You want to do this.
And then steer now has mar soc,
which you can just go in and you can be a special operations guy for your whole
career.
What is closed loop?
What does that mean?
Meaning?
So what I just said about the marine corps,
like now you can go in the marine corps and you can just be in special
operations for your whole career.
Before you could go for what would,
how,
how long of a tour where they do two or three deployments at a,
at a special,
I don't think it was like a three year tour or six years.
They would do it a command and then I'd have to go somewhere else.
They might go back to an infantry unit or or something like that.
And that's called like a open loop open loop,
meaning that you don't necessarily stay in the job you want the whole time.
Now
at what point did you start listening to heavy metal punk rock and hardcore
music?
Cause I know that's the first like connection you and I had,
which I don't know,
is there some weird sort of thing when you just like look at some other guide
bourbon?
The dude,
this guy's into hardcore.
I,
I mean it's not little.
It's not like I walked up and said,
hey,
what kind of music do you like?
It would just like immediate,
you just know,
right?
Yeah.
It,
I don't know what the bone of fees are actually on that.
Um,
yeah,
shoot,
I explored around with like a lot of different music and it just wasn't enough.
You know,
it's like,
oh,
okay,
well I'll listen to the doors strikeouts.
I liked them for a little bit in man then,
and it was kind of an investment to buy an album back in those days or to find
even any punk rock.
So I found,
I think like a dead Kennedys album,
fresh fruit for rotting vegetables.
That was kind of like my gateway drug.
Uh,
and then I'm like,
oh,
okay,
this is really getting me moving.
Um,
then I remember,
I think I was 14 or 15 when I went to my first show up at UC Irvine.
It was like pil,
which was Johnny rotten span.
And uh,
I,
I saw,
you know,
and in a mosh pit was just like,
what is this?
I want to live here.
I want to get a mailbox right outside this thing and just stay in here at this
point of friction circling around and around forever.
And I was like,
boom.
That was it.
Then,
you know,
discovered Gbh and Orange County had a really,
really like probably a one of the biggest scenes in the world at the time for
all the music that would come through there or was going out of there.
So Gbh,
uh,
the Dui uniform choice was,
was guys and I glommed in later in high school.
Those guys were awesome than an,
and you knew the guys from uniform?
No,
I didn't,
but I really liked their music and I liked their message because some of the
other stuff like,
okay,
rage against the machine for instance.
Yeah,
I liked the music.
I just can't get behind the lyrics,
you know,
or Cro mags.
That was a great example.
I love the music and I like the lyrics to cause it's good,
like get after it stuff so,
and then they're just maybe that that buzzing.
I don't know what guys did in other wars when for sure no music to go in and
listen to listening to kill them all instead of listening to puff the Magic
Dragon.
Right?
That's literally what's what Americans were listening to.
Like they're listening to puff the magic dragon and those folk music bands.
And I mean,
I guess maybe at the outside edge somebody might've been listening to Hendrix or
something.
That's a little harder.
But yeah.
Yeah.
To me there's a,
there's a,
this is just straight up the way it is.
Some human beings,
I would say normally boys have this thing in their head that wants to fight and
wants to break things.
And,
and,
and when you hear your example,
the doors,
you're like,
okay,
well this is,
you know,
you hear light my fire and you're okay.
Like I'm kind of,
I'm feeling a little something there.
And then you hear the Crow Max and you go,
oh,
okay.
You hear Motorhead and you go,
oh,
okay,
this is,
this is me,
this is what I'm talking about right here.
I completely understand this music right now.
Yeah.
And in that trust,
and they can just pick it up and other people.
Yeah.
Then so
that,
and then like I stuck with punk rock for a long time and then a buddy of mine in
high school who I swam with Steve Rosenthal is like,
hey,
you should check out Metallica.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
And then they were like,
they crossed me over to where I'm like,
oh no,
now I like speed metal too.
And then finally I found my way to slayer and kind of stuck with them forever
and slayers on a continual loop in the back of my head all the time.
And it's always surfacing up or down.
Um,
but now it's like really by exception that I listened to it because it just
can't listen to it all day.
I can be that fired up,
but still really good.
Yeah,
it is.
And so then you enlisted in the navy,
you go to bus and this time,
what years it,
uh,
I went in [inaudible] 87 and then up to great lakes.
Did Gunner's mate a school up there?
Uh,
and so I think I checked into bud sometime in May or June of [inaudible] 88 and
eight
paired where you for buds,
you know,
a lot of people don't listen to this.
We'll think they want to go to buds or whatever and they're paranoid about what
they can do to prepare.
And I know,
I'm assuming you probably did something similar to why did,
cause we had no idea what was going on.
Having no idea what the training was like the video,
you probably watched the same video as me if they even had that video.
That one special.
Yeah.
So he wants to be someone special and you think,
well,
in order to get ready for the seal teams,
what I need to do is look cool,
wear all black and be cool.
But there was no,
Hey,
here's the protocol to get good at pull ups.
Here's the protocol to get good at swimming with fins.
None of that.
No,
no.
And it then,
you know,
like in bootcamp I have found that we actually got out of shape,
me and the other,
there was another guy in,
in,
in my bootcamp class that actually just retired as a mass chief as well.
And we would go in the bathroom and do pull ups in on the stalls just to try and
stay in shape.
Um,
one thing I didn't do enough is Brian,
it's I hated running and then I was in every goon squad until I think third
phase.
Then it clicked and I was already a really good swimmers in the water.
Wasn't an issue for me,
but I was just hammering a goon goon squad,
you know,
it's when you're towards the back of the deal and,
and they're like,
okay,
you guys are done.
You're,
you're doing this run.
The rest of you start doing pushups,
hit the surf and they just mess with you forever.
Feel like the first,
all through first phase,
every time Darren,
I threw up because I was gonna,
I was like inches in front of failing and just had to reach deep and,
and push,
push it across the finish line.
You said there were some what,
what happened at Sanko you were telling me the other day about something
happens.
Sank.
Oh,
what was that?
So it was like before you started training free training,
they said,
hey,
we need volunteers to come out to San Clemente island to help out with,
uh,
the class that was was out there and you'd just kind of go and work behind the
scenes with the staff out there at San Clemente island.
And so I think like the second night,
uh,
I was out there,
we were in Chow and instructors and students are eating in the same room as this
little quonset hut.
And they had,
it was Taco night.
And so there was a big sign up there when you went up to get served.
Like,
Hey,
only two tacos.
So when I got up there,
the cook is like,
there was only one taco left.
He goes,
hey,
just come back when I'm making some more,
come back up here and get one.
So I hit my one Taco,
went back up to get my next one.
He's like,
here you go.
And as I'm walking with my tray back,
one of the instructor says to me,
Hey,
didn't you already eat two tacos?
And I'm like,
oh my goodness,
I didn't know what to do.
So I said,
no.
And then I tried to keep going.
Well it was the phase officer,
you know,
he wasn't wearing any rank,
insignia,
Sudan,
all the other instructors leap up.
They're all huge and they just start screaming at me and I'm thinking to myself
or I've already ruined it.
So we got an even eat the Taco.
I just got out of there and I went back to uh,
where you know,
our little hut,
where we were sleeping and I just went to bed.
It was like at 5:00 PM because I was like,
oh no.
Then the next morning at 4:00 AM,
there's a knock on the door and one of the guys opens up the door and it's one
of the students that's actually in the class.
And he goes,
Hey,
is there a gardener in here?
And then everyone just looks at me,
you know,
and uh,
and I'm like,
yeah,
I'm back here.
And they go,
they want you down at the beach.
So I got dressed and went down there.
You know,
I feel like I'm going to Castle Dracula and like,
Oh,
what are they gonna do to me?
So the instructors are all circled up in the phase officer's there.
He goes,
Gardiner,
get over here.
It's like over there.
And he goes,
he hands me a thermometer and he goes,
we need to get the Watertown.
So you're going to go out in the water up to your waist and you're going to stay
there and do not you.
I need you to go all the way to your waist and you going to stay there for two
minutes.
Don't come in early.
And I'm like,
who?
Yah.
So I take it and I just go,
I go out until I'm just treading water.
But as I,
I'm like,
ah,
I see how this is going to go.
Right.
So then,
and I didn't even look at my watch,
I just stayed there until finally they're like getting your dummy.
So I come running in and hand him the uh,
uh,
thermometer and they check it was like 53 degrees or something like that and
they're like,
get out of your gardener.
And uh,
they did did this like one other time and then they just decided it's not going
to be fun to pick on this guy.
And that's what I kind of figured was going on.
I just like,
oh,
okay.
Um,
don't give them a reaction.
Don't give them reaction.
And uh,
and then they,
they went to,
I found someone else to mess with,
but the guys in the class later told me that the group of pre trainings that was
out there before our group came out.
Like they had one guy that they would just harass and they would just make them
burst into tears every time.
In the end quitting before even started training.
But you know,
you talk about this a lot on the podcast,
how seal platoons are just super aggressive and they're like anybody looking for
any weakness and if you show weakness it's going to get hammered and then you're
like,
no response,
no response.
You got to,
you got to have normal face stifle your emotions or your life is going to be
miserable until you figure out how to deal with whatever that weakness is.
The thing.
There's a couple things that really bothered me in the world.
Uh,
and I won't tell anyone what they are.
No one knows.
Not One single person knows what really,
really like.
There's a couple things.
If I,
if a seal platoon would have known these things,
I would have been eaten alive.
But I never ever say,
and I won't tell anyone right now ever,
I'll put it in my will when I die.
It'll be like,
hey,
you
guys missed a huge opportunity because I know and sometimes it's things that can
happen with team guys just anyways,
just things happen and if you let it show you're doomed.
You are or,
or they just hammered that weakness until that nerve is dead and it doesn't
bother you anymore.
Get to work you through it in a nice gentle way.
And did you have any,
so you,
you,
you were crappy runner obviously,
and you,
so that was a gut check.
That's like me.
I every run,
I failed one run after that run every run I did.
I just ran as hard as I possibly could sprint for the,
for until we were done,
until I was done.
Uh,
would,
did anything else trip you up at all in buds because every,
all the water stuff was easy.
Pool comp,
lifesaving,
all that stuff was easy cause you did water.
Yeah.
And nothing about buds is easy,
but um,
it was all stuff that I was really accustomed to.
And so the,
so it was like,
uh,
this is no big deal.
It's just no big deal.
That,
but it,
it was freaking brutal.
Like I wouldn't do it.
I wouldn't want to do it again,
that's for sure.
Um,
and then,
but the truth of it is like as cool as I was in buds,
colder in the team,
so I was tired.
I was in buds,
tired around the team.
So yeah.
Um,
great guys.
It was a great experience.
I finished up,
did you finish up with dive face?
I finished with a land warfare,
so they switched it somewhere around when I was there,
which was 1991 that's,
it was just before we got there that we switched to,
in fact,
I think there was actually a class that did it the opposite way.
Did it the old way,
the way you did it before,
right.
That that was still there when I got there.
So
right.
It was because of pool calm is because it puts so many guys get kicked out
during pool comp that they're like,
why are we waiting until the end to do this?
Let's shift it over.
Yeah.
Pool competency is something that I knew zero about when I was coming into the,
into buds.
And they had,
they had a poster in the med medical area by the grinder over there and it was a
Texas chainsaw massacre poster.
And,
and yet they had written the Texas or the buds pool comp massacre and it had
like a guy with a regulator getting ripped out of his mouth and,
and who's the killer?
And um,
oh,
Leatherface Leatherface was,
you know,
like how to like an EDT seal instructor tee shirt on.
And I just remember walking by it,
I was checking in or whatever and I go,
oh,
I wonder what that's all about.
And then I found out that,
yeah,
they're going to,
they're going to crush you in the water.
And what about then you go to,
you went to old school,
airborne school.
Oh yeah.
How's that for you?
So it was really good,
but I was,
you know,
I was really,
really cocky and when I go back and examine my cockiness,
it was just,
here's the deal.
I was super insecure and uh,
and then compensate for it by being cocky and a hope,
hopes it no one figures out how insecure I am.
But anyway,
uh,
the physical aspect of jump school,
you know,
runs and stuff,
it's so easy and then,
but you kind of get throttled back where it's kind of a bootcamp mentality.
You're not used to it.
So me and the guys we were going out drinking on and there's rules you're not
supposed to drink on a week night.
And we were out drinking on a weeknight or it was like a Sunday night on the
night before,
one of the last,
before the final week of jump weeks.
And,
uh,
I went up to get a pitcher of beer at the bar there.
And,
uh,
the guy who was the bartender turns out he was a black cat.
And so he's like,
Hey,
are you jump school?
And I'm like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I'm a jump school.
And he goes,
you're not supposed to be drinking on weeknights.
And then I,
I'm like,
yeah,
well,
whatever.
And he goes,
do you know who I am?
And,
and I said,
no.
And he goes,
I'm a black cat.
And he said it in a manner where like,
there should've been some spooky music playing behind it and a,
um,
and I was like,
okay,
well if you don't think I can,
you know,
drink this beer and do the PT and running in the morning and you're out of your
mind.
And He,
and he's like,
get out of my bar,
rightly so,
kicked me out.
So we leave the next morning we're on the bus on the way to the drop zone for
the first jump and there's kind of a commotion outside.
And I look,
and there's that guy that was the bartender with his and he's with one of our
guys,
cause he was in a different phase.
And so they pulled everybody off.
The bus lined us up,
he walked down,
he goes,
Oh,
here's the guy.
They blew me out of the lineup,
um,
pulled me behind,
uh,
one of the buildings and tuned me up,
you know,
I kinda deserved,
I did,
didn't it kind of,
I deserved it.
And so they let me have it.
And then that was it.
I went back and did three or four more jumps and then I was getting ready to do
my fifth jump,
which is the last jump there at jump school.
And uh,
the liaison officer came and pulled me out and said,
hey,
you were drinking on a week night.
I've got the statement,
you're,
I'm pulling you out of this thing and I'm going to take you to Njp,
which nonjudicial punishment,
copies mass.
So I was like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
These guys chewed me out,
you know,
tuned me up a little bit.
By that,
I mean a gut punched me and I had,
you know,
had it come in,
it's all good and uh,
you know,
it was going to be done there.
And he goes,
nope,
we're not having this.
This isn't it.
So you're,
you're going to go to mass.
So I got pulled out of the class,
the class graduated and left,
and then this is like Friday,
you know,
they did their last jump to the graduation.
I was got put in a holding company and then I went to captain's mast
in front of the Marine Corps,
Lieutenant colonel that was kind of like the officer out there and towards the
navy and Marines going through jump school and uh,
you know,
I,
my dad,
because he was still active duty at the time and he's like a Jag and Jag score.
Yeah.
But he couldn't pull any strings.
He's like,
Hey,
you're just going to have to go in there and own it.
So I go in,
I,
you know,
I sit,
sit in the room,
coming into the guy's office.
They read me the rights,
they read the statement against me,
which,
which is basically the story I just told you today.
Any Bella still a little bit more,
but it's all good.
And so
the colonel,
he reads his stuff and then he just looks up at me and I'm standing at attention
and I'm,
I think I'm okay.
I've done it again.
I'm going to get thrown out.
And he goes,
uh,
do you,
do you have anything to say for yourself?
And I said,
uh,
sir,
that's pretty much what happened.
You know,
the statement that he read out.
And I said,
uh,
I've embarrassed the navy and by and turn the Marine Corps and all I can do is
take my lumps and press on with my career.
And then he just stared at me and he goes,
I find you 100 bucks for one month and I'll let you reclass up with the next
class and do your final jump and get outta here.
And so you got $100 extra a month jump pay.
So it was really kind of a wash.
It was awesome.
And then the,
the one guy that had pulled me out of line and,
and brought me in there to mass,
he's like,
you know,
who told you what to say?
But I found that,
and I've always told young guys in the military career,
just own it.
If you get in trouble,
own,
it's when you make excuses that you run into trouble.
But when you're like,
this is what I did.
Most things that people have done,
guys have come close to doing or didn't just didn't get in trouble for.
And when you own it,
it just works out better in the end to those every time.
No doubt about that.
Uh,
so now you go back to back to the team,
very your team five,
checking a team five.
We didn't have SQT then.
So what they did with us was,
uh,
we just kind of bounced around.
So I worked in a different department at the team that worked in diving for a
couple of weeks.
Works,
worked in ordinance for a couple of weeks.
And I think I was at the team for about four months and in those days of the
team didn't deploy,
we all always had two platoons pushed forward and the command was back.
So,
uh,
I think I was probably four or five months at the team.
Went out to Niland,
worked at the old cap camp out there as a camp guard,
was great experience.
And uh,
and then,
uh,
got in my first platoon,
which was an arg alpha.
So we did the whole deployment on a ship.
And,
uh,
that was,
that was great.
Had done some awesome guys in that platoon.
A platoon chief was his guy named Bill Kune,
who's passed away now and it really miss him,
but he was just super even Keel,
quiet,
direct.
You never really saw him lose his temper and a,
a good,
good man.
Good example for all of us.
And then,
uh,
and then a couple other guys I'll get into here in a second.
Uh,
you know,
and then we wound up deploying on the ship and we did a longer workup.
Then it was,
we did a,
like almost a year long workup because we were going in the Ark.
We had to do everything.
Guys were normally doing like an eight month or,
and then they do a six months to Pei.
Yeah.
Well,
well,
when I did,
because I did two arcs,
you know,
for those of you who don't know it's deploying on a ship.
When we did that,
it would be,
we'd do the normal workup,
but we do the normal workup before we started our interoperability with the navy
and the Marine Corps.
So that tacked on that that text on their workup,
the Navy workup in the Marine Corps workup.
So it was like we did two workups kind of and it was awesome training.
I got so much out of out of that.
But then where did you,
where'd you guys go on deployment?
Well we started in our west pack and we were,
we'd just gotten into the Philippines when the Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait and
all that stuff kicked off.
So then we pushed over for Operation Desert Shield and then was a thought we
were going to go home.
We made it back to the Philippines and then we stopped there and the Pi for like
three weeks and then turn back around and went back over for a Operation Desert
Storm.
Did you guys do anything?
We just did a bump.
So we did,
uh,
the tanker boardings sure.
Like you talk about did a couple of those and then we had a bunch of different
operations that we had slated on some of the islands off the coast there that we
would,
we got all the way to the point of doing rehearsals forum.
And then like the Iraqis would have just abandon the island or a cup.
One of the times when the Halos flew over to do a recon,
they surrendered to the helicopters and they just sent helicopters in there and
took all,
took all the Rockies over.
But uh,
um,
admiral McRaven was our task unit commander at the time and uh,
so that was cool.
He,
he was,
he was really good to work for.
And then,
uh,
like one of the guys in the platoon that I,
that I told you I reached out to him cause I wanted to mention him because he's
kind of a bigger than life seal was Steve Hines.
And Steve is,
is,
he's a big guy.
He's all,
you know,
at the time,
tatted up quite a bit,
which in the early nineties,
a lot,
not a lot of the guys had tattoos.
He,
uh,
at some point in a bar fight,
someone had cut him up with a knife.
So he has these amazing scars,
criss crossing his chest.
He's really smart.
He's got a razor sharp wit wit and was just a lot of fun to work with.
One of those guys,
where is,
he is bad as things ever got.
He's always cracking,
you know,
cracking jokes.
So it's always funny.
Takes the edge off it.
And one of the things that he did really well was,
you know,
when you're on a ship,
you're on the ship and there are some guys that decide they're going to be
condescending to everybody and uh,
you know,
it just doesn't get you far in life.
Steve Brand,
uh,
PT for the ship.
So we would do our own physical training in the morning.
And then he had one that he would run in the afternoon and he would invite
everybody to it.
And the captain of the ship came to his PT,
the master chief for the ship was there.
Um,
by the end of the deployment we would have,
most of the flight deck would be covered with guys coming to his PT and then
he'd be cracking jokes the whole time everybody loved him.
We would do like,
okay,
hey,
we're going to do a fantail shoot.
And we would have different people from the ship come up and we would let them
shoot our guns and be their range safety officers.
So it's like,
hey,
all the guys that work in the Galley,
you know in the galleys are mess hall,
come out,
we're going to run a shoot for you.
And then then what happens?
They hook you up with food,
you know,
you everybody chicken patties,
chicken patties,
you know,
maybe some extra dessert.
And then everybody just looked out for us and it was so good.
It paid off in spades
and I'm,
the of building relationships with people is just such a benefit across the
board and I certainly learned that literally getting extra chicken patties and
extra chicken nuggets because I was bros with the dude working in the front line
and and out the chicken nuggets.
What might sound like,
like that's whatever.
No,
that's a real thing.
You're cutting gator squares off the coast of Africa for 90 days.
They,
they don't have a lot of food left and it gets down to,
okay,
what are we going to get worse?
You're out there trying to get jacked by the way.
And if you,
if you don't have fuel,
so yeah,
bro out with those people a little bit.
Everybody why is just like no skin off your back not to.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know what I mean?
Really that's what Karma is,
right?
Yeah.
Good to people.
And then it comes back to you.
Yeah.
And so,
so you guys did some shit boardings and,
but then the Gulf war happened.
He was over in 72 hours when the done really quick.
And the guys in the teams that did do missions,
they,
they were generally like a couple of guys.
There's a couple tunes that got,
it was a couple of tunes.
There's a platoon that almost got over random,
didn't get over coffee.
Right.
That was one platoon.
Um,
no.
Was it,
I think it was a team one platoon,
but was it a no,
it wasn't what it was,
but it was right up there lying and they punched through.
It was pretty crazy.
Yeah.
That's like one of the,
and one of the guys that was in that platoon I ended up in a platoon with later.
But generally,
and even even doing shit boardings back then was like,
yes,
you know,
we did something real world,
real world,
real world up,
everybody gather around.
And that was the truth.
That was the truth.
That was,
that was the way it was.
Hey,
if you did something real,
that was awesome.
And,
and I mean when I was coming in,
I had all these fantasies that once I was in the seal teams,
look,
there's clandestine wars going on worldwide and I'm going to be all up in them.
I'm going to be fighting wars people don't even know about.
And then I found out when I got to the teams that there was no wars in Guam,
which was where my first deployment went to.
Yeah.
I felt like that same thing was going on that there'd be like guys with,
you'd get there and within a week people do on a,
load your stuff up,
we're going here and load and everything out and then it doesn't happen that way
or it does.
You just got to,
you can't chase it,
I guess.
Well,
it happens more now.
I mean,
now there's a lot more stuff going on.
Edit is going on and it is worldwide and you see it in the news and sometimes
you don't.
But it is totally different.
It's completely different now.
I mean,
we are at war.
And so those little fantasies that you have about going into countries though,
that that happens now,
whereas in the 90s wasn't happening.
No.
And then there are all these assumptions about what you're going to do when
you're shot at.
I remember like we shifted our,
our immediate action drills around,
um,
at an island right after the Panama thing happened,
that Patea airstrip.
And they,
and we decided that,
or it was decided by guys thinking about it.
They're like,
hey,
you're just when,
uh,
when the first gunshot goes,
you're just going to crawl.
So we did everything crawling around in the desert and uh,
you know,
it's not,
it's not how it goes,
but no one knew.
No one knew.
And we lacked simunition or,
or laser systems that we ended up using.
And so it was hard to know.
I mean even CQC was,
oh specially,
totally ridiculous what we used to do.
And you know,
new guys like me,
they're telling me that this is what you do and this is why you do it.
Cause they have theories behind it.
They have theories theoretically.
And the theories are hard to argue with a because you don't know any better.
And B,
because they've kind of pressure tested the theories in little arguments amongst
themselves.
So Hey,
you listen to them and you take,
okay this is the way it is.
And then you find out,
well then everyone found out actually,
even just when they started implementing paintballing simunition it was like,
you know what,
this doesn't seem like a smart idea.
It doesn't seem like a smart idea for all of us to be standing in the hallway.
That's the,
that's one of the big ones.
It's so obvious.
You know,
my first platoon it was like,
hey everyone standing in the hallway and you get ready to go in the next room
and that's cool.
Then second platoon,
same way.
It wasn't till either,
like I think it was even passed.
I think it was,
I think it was in,
um,
I don't know,
I'm trying to think of the year,
but like 98 is when I started seeing a change in,
hey,
this is not smart because watch what happens.
You guys are all line up in the hallway.
Cool.
Somebody sticks,
a simunition gone around the corner of the hallway and Mo's down eight people.
Right.
And the first reaction is like,
well that wouldn't happen.
It just happened.
Well that guy wasn't aiming.
Yeah,
you don't need to aim,
you have an automatic weapon.
And so that was kind of the beginning or that,
that definitely had an impact on the way stuff is going to be.
And it's just like you said,
like you talked about in Panama,
those guys and how the guy's made theoretical changes,
which is,
hey,
when the shooting starts,
you're going to crawl well in the desert.
Your contact is likely to be much further away and you have much greater
distance to travel in order to break contact or to assault.
So if,
if what you're doing is called not saying,
there's no times where you will be sucking mud,
cause you certainly can be,
but there's a difference between effective fire and ineffective fire and there's
this difference between dead space and when you're in an open space where you
can actually get hit.
So yeah,
it's weird.
It was awesome and weird to see all that unfold.
And it is actually very similar to what the UFC did do martial arts,
you know,
because because everything was theoretical.
And again,
it was,
you remember some of the kind of weird martial arts that they'd throw at us and
the teams and I remember one in particular where it was,
hey,
when you hit the guy here,
his,
I forget what they called it,
they had a scientific name for it,
his automatic reaction,
but they had some scientific sounding word.
His automatic reaction is physiological reaction is going to be to do this and
then when they do that you can do this and then when and when you do this it's
going to cause him to that and they had these big scenarios that would,
they would play out and that was what it was.
Hey,
when you get it from there,
like it was literally when you hit the guy in the neck,
it's going to cause him to like fold to one side and,
and,
and everyone that gets hit in the neck arches,
they're back in,
sticks their chin out,
then you'll hit him with this.
It was there,
there that that's what they're saying.
And then you can't say,
well,
hey man,
go ahead and like hit me in the neck with all your mind.
And I actually did do that.
I actually did say like,
hit me,
see if that happens.
And it didn't happen.
And then I got some other weird psychobabble circular argument about,
well that's because you're expecting it.
Well,
okay,
but do it when I'm not expert.
You know,
it just,
it's just one of these things.
Strike the,
stomp the groin,
rake the eyes,
restart the groin.
What was that?
It was the,
was it the scars was like a soft combat assault system or something like that.
It was,
and we got,
we went through a whole bunch of those.
And all it takes is a couple of people in a leadership position to get convinced
by this [inaudible].
I notice I always saw a lot of circular arguments in those things and it's so
that,
that thing,
so when the UFC started,
it was like,
oh,
these Kung Fu guys or whatever,
these karate guys or whatever,
these Ninjitsu guys or whatever,
whatever their martial art was.
And they had the thing that,
oh,
when I drove punch you,
you're breathing will be incapacitated for approximately 45 seconds.
It's generally about 45 seconds.
When you hit someone in the throat,
in order for the nucleus,
about a 45 seconds,
you've got about a 45 second window where now you want to attack the nerve
basis,
you want to attack the solar plexus when you get them in the solar plexus
profitably.
Now you've got about another 45 seconds this week and rake the eyes
I'm doing some grand master can stick that.
That was it man.
And,
and so when the UFC came around it was like,
oh all of a sudden that doesn't work.
And it's the same thing that happened pre and I'll even say priests,
ammunition,
pre paint ball and pre and we use miles gear.
But miles gay was kind of weak.
Miles get wasn't quite good enough,
which is for those of you don't know,
it's like a laser tag system that you mounted on your wheel weapons.
But it wasn't very accurate.
You had to deal with jams in your blanks and it was just,
it wasn't that good.
Yeah.
But those things definitely started to make it lean towards,
oh,
this,
this theory doesn't seem to hold the water that we all thought that had held.
Yeah.
It was just,
but you know what,
here's the thing.
Even if we were crawling,
as long as we had a plan and rehearsed it,
that was way better than stuff that wasn't.
So a lot of those guys that did that first,
those first fighting systems,
that there was a lot of goofy stuff when they would get in a street fight,
they would still do okay.
Because what's I think patents said that thing about a good plan now is better
than a perfect plan later.
You know?
And that's a good point.
Now that I think about it,
if you think about the tactics,
so you got told after Panama to crawl and that seems kind of crazy right now.
And in a,
if you think about it as a broad,
hey,
what we're gonna do is call the whole time to think about this though.
Remember when it was a whole squad getting up online and moving,
get them getting up and running all at one time.
Yeah.
Just as ridiculous.
Just ridiculous.
Exactly.
And there's a time and place for both things.
There's a time and place for both things.
And you know,
as mentoring,
I was,
I was at uh,
one of the teams,
I don't know,
six months ago,
a year ago when we were talking tactics and a guy asked me like,
hey,
where does the argument,
I might have even been your team.
The,
the question was like,
where does the commander go in this situation?
And it was like one group was saying they shouldn't be in the rear and the other
group is saying,
no,
there should be an the,
it was my team and I was like,
listen,
there's different times where the commander needs to be in a different spot.
And where the commander should be is where he isn't in the weeds but still kind
of understands what's happening and can provide the mess,
command and control.
So the answer is not he should be here.
The answer is
where should he be for that particular situation?
And does the commander have the understanding,
the tactical understanding and the operational understanding to go,
oh,
you know what,
if these guys are busting into a building right here and I go into that building
and there's contact,
I'm going to be sucked into that contract and I'm not gonna be able to control
anything contrary to that.
If I'm way at the back where the contact happens and I don't even know what
building it's in,
that's a problem too.
Where should I be?
I should be where I can provide the best command and control.
And that's very adaptable.
It's very easy to adapt,
but it's very also very easy for people to come up with doctrine and then
supporting arguments,
supporting theories that,
that are very hard to argue against because you get into circular arguments
against crazy people.
Yeah.
Ooh,
become emotionally attached to whatever the answer.
Oh,
that's a stinger.
And this is why I think NSW is all,
has been so successful and I think it'll continue to be successful is because
we're not so rigid in what we do.
And it's so it in in one ways it's a weakness but it's also at the same time our
greatest strength because everything I've done on deployment,
most things actually was not exactly something that I trained for.
But the training that I got was 30% there to where it was easy to pivot and boom
in do whatever,
whatever's being requested overseas.
Yeah.
And the training that you got trained you to think trains you to think,
not just,
hey,
this is what you're going to do 100% of the time.
It's like,
Hey,
this is going to work in this situation,
but you should be looking around.
You should have your head on a swivel.
You should be looking for work.
All those little,
those little like mantras that you get told,
they actually make sense cause it's not just do the same thing every time it's
read and react.
Right.
They didn't react.
That's one of the first things you started hearing like read and react because
you don't just do,
you actually read and you actually assess.
So those are all important.
Uh,
anything else from that first deployment besides just being on the Oregon?
You know,
I man,
hot long 10 month deployment.
I remember it by the end of the deployment.
After that deployment,
none of us wanted to talk to each other for a while.
It was like you'd see guys around the corner,
hey and then,
cause it was just so long and there's no internet,
there's no internet,
you know,
communication with home is snail mail letters takes three week conversations you
have back and forth and,
and the whole platoon is in a room that's twice the size of this.
The racks are stacked four high.
You've got like 80 movies on videotape and they're just running constantly.
And you've seen every one of these
80 movies,
uh,
500 times because they're literally playing nonstop.
And the platoon space,
it's ridiculous.
We got on a kick in,
this is another arg deployment I went on later when I'm going to Somalia,
but we got on a kick with uh,
oh,
what's the movie where the girls had spins around and exercise.
So we're watching the exorcist over and over and over again and write about,
that was the time we did the,
uh,
the shell back ceremony where we went over the equator.
And so there was only two guys in the platoon that had done it.
So all the rest of us were blogs and we were going through it.
And,
uh,
basically all they do is throw food at humans,
brand new with water,
which,
okay,
is it like buds?
We were just doing it and guys would come by with like,
oh look at these walks over here.
And I remember one of the guys going thought,
power of Christ compels the power of Christ,
compels you.
And then we all started shouting in and the guy just looked at us for a second
and wandered off and someone else came behind with a hose and spray just a
little bit,
but they had no idea what to make of us at all.
Uh,
awesome.
you come home from that deployment and then what?
Then what's up?
What's next?
Then I went and worked in the armory for a little bit and waited to pick up
another,
another platoon den.
After that I did
worked in your armory for another six months,
did another platoon.
And then that was a Spec.
You went to the armory because you were interested in,
was it gunner's mate and so I was a ordinance.
What,
what position were you and your first platoon?
Oh,
good point.
So I was a sniper,
but they didn't,
we didn't have NSW,
you didn't have a sniper course.
So there was a guy that had just come from reappointment point man and second
squad.
And the first squad point man was a sniper and he'd been to the army sniper
school.
So they ran,
ran me through some different training and stuff like that to get me like kind
of qualified,
but I didn't have a certificate or nothing.
And it was really,
um,
minor stuff.
So me and the other sniper would,
you know,
practice just calling stuff out.
And then when we do the tech of boardings,
I'd be up in the Hilo eyes above passing info.
And,
uh,
so when I got back,
I went to,
um,
I was working in ordinance and then I got an opportunity to go to the second NSW
sniper course they ran on the west coast.
And,
uh,
that was,
that was brutal.
Um,
I've never failed anything.
Up until then,
I'd never failed anything in my life and I didn't make it through the first
sniper course.
I passed the shooting portion,
which most guys pass,
but,
uh,
and that was like five weeks straight of shooting.
But then when it came to stalking,
I just didn't get it.
And,
uh,
a lack,
the patience that I needed that I later figured it out.
And so I didn't pass.
I came out of there without,
not a sniper call,
but an advanced marksman qual,
um,
badge of dishonor.
Yeah,
pretty much.
And uh,
guys,
so actually it's funny because I say that jokingly,
but like everybody knows that how hard that they used to fail everyone in stock.
And it was crazy.
Mike my course,
there's only two guys that graduated with a call with a sniper quoll out of
like,
how much are the animals?
How much of that was the seal instructor,
Bro team guys going,
we're going to have the hardest course ever.
No one's going to make it through.
It's going to be the toughest course.
I right.
I don't,
yeah,
I mean,
I mean if I would've been in that position,
I think there was,
there was definitely a piece of that because there was like some guys getting
pretty Dang excited and screaming and yell at you every yard line and you're
like,
good grief,
what's going on?
And uh,
um,
but I don't know if that would have made a difference for me passing or not.
Like had it been more leveled out and they hadn't gotten too excited about it,
which I'm not saying they did,
but that's just,
that's how it rolled out.
So second and I,
I platooned up and I was again,
a point man.
And then I think I acted as a sniper,
but then the sniper thing kind of fell off the radar for NSW a little bit.
It wasn't a priority for anybody.
And,
uh,
did a second platoon,
which is a spec ops platoon went to the Philippines or no,
we went to Guam.
That's where we met at the jungle in Guam.
And,
and the jungle was his bar,
the judge,
everybody in jungle.
The jungle was the bar that everybody went to.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
did that platoon,
then I wound up doing a year overseas.
Well,
I went home for a week and then came back with another platoon straightaway and
did,
did that.
And those were great experiences.
I mean,
we traveled around a lot.
Um,
we did a lot of water work back in the day,
a lot of tank tanker boarding,
a lot of diving,
all,
all that,
didn't do anything real.
And then when I came back from those deployments,
I went to work in,
uh,
our training cell at the team.
Um,
and the guy I was working in the land warfare section working for a guy named,
uh,
Danny Carol,
who at the time was,
uh,
and I'm gonna have to back up a little bit on this,
but,
uh,
he,
he was just,
he was awesome to work for.
He's,
he's one of these guys that no matter how bad anything ever was,
he never complained.
He might complain to someone that was his peer,
but he never complained down and then never complained about,
oh,
this is stupid.
Or he was not the tortured genius,
which when things were hard and he wasn't complaining,
then it wasn't hard.
And He,
he's another guy with a really good sense of humor,
um,
and uh,
and just a good,
good time to be around.
But the biggest thing about him was just like never,
ever complained.
Always something positive to say.
Um,
and,
and was,
was an expert.
And then when he did give you a critique,
he didn't,
it wasn't condescending.
So he was somebody I looked up to when he wasn't in my platoon and he's actually
a leadership and my sister platoon.
And I would go over and talk to him all the time.
And like back in the day I had my hair bleached white.
It was always long.
You know,
I was never in the right uniform ever because not being in uniform made me feel
special because I was insecure and uh,
all,
all people would just scream at me,
cut your hair,
get in uniform.
But they never would tell you,
you know,
hey,
do it.
Then one day Danny goes,
Hey Jason,
why don't you,
why don't you cut your hair?
It's so easy to have a decent haircut and be in the right uniform and your life
is going to be so much better and you should just try it for a little bit.
And he just laid it out and it,
there was no condescension behind.
It was just straight up advice from one friend to another.
And uh,
um,
and so I tried it and I was like,
hey,
this is amazing.
People aren't asking like,
Hey,
what are you doing tonight?
People were actually giving me stuff to do and then leaving me alone and let me
do it cause they,
they trusted me that I was going to be,
you know,
be professional about it.
And after and working for him,
I got the opportunity because when the teams ran sniper courses,
I got to interject real quick cause there's also those guys that would be like,
they're condescending and all you do is,
you know the guy that's all straight laced running around the team looking like
a Dork.
And you just think when you're a young team guy,
you're like,
this guy's a dork.
He doesn't eat as it.
And if they come up and say something and you're just mad at him,
you know,
you're just like,
you're stupid.
You don't get it.
You don't know what it's like to be young Jocko.
Right.
And that's how everybody else was was for me.
Cause you're like,
really?
But you know,
Danny was a beast and then so it was like,
yeah,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna listen to what he's saying.
You know,
there's an important two things about Steve Hines and,
and Danny,
which I didn't work with either of those guys other than peripheral peripherally
through through the years.
You know,
I think Steve Hines put was that free fall school with WHO's at an island
forever.
So whatever.
And Danny,
Carol,
well I didn't,
I remember Danny from being on deployment and hit my Lpo was good friends with
him.
And so,
you know,
we were always linked up and,
but what I was going to say is,
you mentioned this real quick,
he was good operator.
Like he was Oh guys that,
cause if you were good at your job,
that's like the base level of having respect in getting people
to listen to you is oh this guy is a really good at his job.
And you'd even here before we,
before the word operator had the,
had the kind of meaning that it has day where it's like,
oh he's an operator.
And it kind of is this taken on a life of its own,
but back then and be like,
oh yeah,
that guy's a good operator.
And it really meant something when I would hear that about someone like,
Hey,
that guy's a really good operator,
and you think,
oh,
wow,
that guys,
that means he can shoot.
Well that means you can navigate well.
That means he can dive well.
That means he's,
he's,
uh,
keeps his cool like meant to all of those things.
That guy's a good operator.
And so that sort of to me was the baseline.
And especially for guys that I
looked up to at my team when I was a new guy,
it was the guys where you'd hear,
oh,
that guy's a really good operator.
And then it was okay.
And it wasn't like that was everyone.
It was not a big number of people.
And,
and to develop a reputation as a good operator when there's no war going on,
it's actually very hard to do that because what that means is every one of these
stupid training missions,
every one of these dumb dives that everyone's bitching about,
you're actually taking completely serious and you're doing your best and you're
teaching other people.
And that is what,
that's what developed the reputation back then was like this guy's a good
operator.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
And so then,
then that guys I have to kind of Wasta where he can hand out advice and then the
fact that he gives it out without being condescending or,
or straight up.
It's just so much.
It's,
it's worth absorbing.
What about,
did you,
so what are the schools,
did you go to,
did you get any,
what about,
did you go to sere school?
Yeah.
How was that good time?
You know,
that that was,
uh,
was it,
I forget when,
I think it was in this period after I did those two platoons that I finally got
sucked into going to see your school.
And uh,
I remember I didn't get waterboarded for some reason in sere school,
but I did kill Anita rattlesnake and they're like,
hey,
you're not supposed to do that.
And then I got caught and then I'm like,
okay,
well,
but this is just in the field training portion where you know,
you're doing patrolling and,
uh,
um,
danger crossings.
That's all you're doing all day.
And then you'd have these little land Nav exercises you're doing,
which were super easy for me cause this is what we did.
So I would just just get them done and be done sleeping and hungry and tried to
eat grasshoppers and everything cause they don't feed you for the whole week.
Uh,
and then when they catch you and they put you into that,
that prison camp.
So the first thing they do is have everybody line up and then they strip you
down naked.
Cause apparently there they're checking you for ticks.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
So then they see all my tattoos and one of the instructors is like,
hey,
this guy's got the mark of the devil because the guys all have that Russian
accent,
right?
Yeah.
So I get,
I get grabbed and then I'm the circle of these instructors and they're like,
he's got the market a devil and they're kind of shoving me back and forth.
And I'm like,
Oh okay this is kind of fun.
This is,
you know,
this isn't a big deal.
And then a guy that straight across from me,
I can remember seeing a big black hand come over his shoulder and it like covers
up half of his chest,
like,
like Andre the giant big and just move the dude away.
And then another guy,
a hand moves the other guy away.
And then there's this just mountain of a man grabbed me with his left hand,
picks me up.
The only allowed to like hit you from out here to here.
But it was like,
you know those those images in rocky where it was like to cook all
stars and not just,
Oh,
that was that little smirk I just had on my face laying on the ground over there
and oh,
here comes again.
Uhm,
and uh,
humbling.
I,
I literally got the exact same treatment.
I remember I was in some vehicle and it was after you got,
you avoided capture and then eventually they just call up in the woods and they
go,
come down and you have to surrender now.
Yeah.
So we had avoided,
captured me and my pilot buddy,
wait,
avoid capture.
We go down and get in the vehicle.
They drive us somewhere and I'm just,
you know,
everything's a joke or whatever and get out of the vehicle and you know,
some guys yelling at us with the fake Russian accent and I'm just laughing at it
inside in,
which means,
you know,
I'm like kind of probably got that.
I was 19.
Yeah.
And the dude,
the dude comes over and he like yells at me and I,
I,
you know,
who knows what I said to prove that I was a tough guy and this dude cracks me.
And I was like,
Eh.
I was like,
I can't believe he just did that.
And okay,
well good times.
So that must be,
they must,
they must know who we are coming in.
They must look at the young punks and go,
Yup,
I got this guy.
Hey I got,
what number is Gardner coming over here from seal team?
Five numbers of willing coming over here from seal team one,
I'm going to get me some money
and it's gonna give them just an immense amount of satisfaction when that look
gets knocked off your face.
Cause they could just see the light come out of your eyes and you're like,
oh
it's a car.
I mean I've been punched many times.
That open hand smack full on and I don't know what you're talking about.
Only bringing it back to wherever.
This brother brought it back all the way and brought it all the way home too.
It was a good one.
And I've been,
like I said,
I've been hit before.
I've been knocked out before.
It didn't knock me out but it was a,
it was definitely a,
it was definitely a reality of Oh yeah these guys or these guys are not playing
around.
These guys are going to take pleasure in beating the crap out of me and they're
going to do it if they,
if I give them any reason to.
So in which that,
so that was two deployments,
you come back,
you're in training.
How much did you learn when you were working in training?
Because I know I as an e five in seal team,
one training cell learned like just mountains of information.
Tons.
Yeah,
exactly.
Cause that's when,
when you have to teach something is when you got to really absorb it because you
have to completely understand it and everything else.
So that's when it opened up the curtain for me.
So I saw everything that went into training that was behind the scenes,
you know,
when you go through the training like Oh,
okay,
well there's a lot that goes on from laying on the ranges to doing the med
drills,
to ordering the Ammo to try to make the training relevant and realistic for the
guy.
So it's,
you just don't feel like you're wasting their time.
But uh,
yeah.
And then it was at that,
at that time that uh,
I went back and restocked and got my sniper quoll and then was an instructor for
a couple of different sniper courses.
Um,
it's got period the differences.
What you,
was there something that you said you didn't get it in the stock in the first
time around?
Was it like you didn't quite figure out dead space was it,
you just didn't have the patience for it where you like whatever on what,
what,
what did you,
what changed about you?
What did you learn in between those two?
I uh,
so they drop you off and then they'll just point,
hey,
the observation point is that way.
And during a stock you're uh,
you're trying to find where these other guys are at and,
and you don't know.
And there other their sniper instructor,
so they have really,
really good skills and optics and they're sitting out somewhere they shouldn't,
not totally concealed,
but you've got to,
you've got to find them before you move.
And the mistake I was making before is that getting impatient and I'm just like,
oh,
I'll just start going that way.
And along the way I'll figure out where they're at and as opposed to,
okay,
I'm going to just sit right here and take my time and figure out where
everything is and how everything is laid out and then try and find the o p
before I move down toward it at all.
You'd have to,
I'd have to move latterly one way or the other to figure it out.
And so typically on the stocks,
when it clicked for me,
I would be the last guy to leak to actually leave where they'd drop us off and
I'd be the first guy done.
And typically I'd spend almost no time crawling because I would do,
do the,
you know,
find the EOP.
Once I had it located,
then I would study their terrain really hard and figured out where I needed to
go to get within that 200 yards to do your,
you know,
final shots,
you figure this out on your own.
Will they tell you that?
But I just started listening to him and,
and,
and it clicked.
They're like,
hey,
you gotta find the oop.
Okay.
Cause Yeah,
isn't
that strange?
I mean,
well your kids,
while you got kids that are old enough,
like it's the same thing with your kids.
You tell them like,
hey,
figure out where the [inaudible] is before you start crawling or whatever.
It is less life lesson that you learned about getting hit in the head with a
baseball bat.
And you try and give your kids a hint or just tell them and they're just like,
no,
I'm just going to start moving.
Yeah,
I got this
and I have no idea how to deal with that.
It's funny because I think you and I have met a lot of the same experiences
with,
with dealing with our kids and you're like,
Hey,
I'm telling you,
I've lived through this.
Here's what you should do.
And,
but now I've come to the point where I'm still going to tell him,
but I know what they're probably going to do.
And then,
yeah.
And then just wait and see.
Keep your fingers crossed,
I guess is what people say.
Okay.
So what I noticed,
one of the things that I,
I'm,
I'm actually thinking about this right now.
When I was in training cell and I was,
because I was single and didn't care about anything else.
And so I taught everything.
It was like,
oh,
there's land warfare trip and goatees land warfare.
Oh,
there's a CQC trip.
Go teach that.
Go teach combat swimmer.
Just teach everything because cause and now I look back how awesome it must be
when you got guys like that at the team who are just like,
oh yeah,
I don't mind going down another month long trip back to back,
doesn't matter.
We'll go train.
And it wasn't just me that was doing,
it's like all my,
all my Bros it,
you know,
I was friends with all my guys from team and we're all saying that like,
hey,
we'll go teach whatever you said it was on the road.
We don't care.
It was awesome.
I had a Volkswagen van that I'd taken all the seats out of the back end,
just line of the carpet and I had some,
some bean bags in there and when I was on the strand I slept in the parking lot
for like I think eight months because I was like,
I would rather be on a trip cla collecting per diem and doing stuff.
Then sitting here and so that's,
that's where,
that's where I want this.
It was always out on training block.
I was running an SQT,
I wasn't running it,
but I was one of the instructors on an Stt when we used to run Stt at the team.
So it was a bunch of new guys.
We were putting them through training.
And I remember right now I'm remembering this,
there was like multiple officers in the same STT class.
So each squad had multiple officers.
So we were rotating through like,
okay,
it's your turn B squad leader to your team during I ads.
And now that I think about it,
I remember so much of looking at like,
okay,
he'd see one guy do it and he'd be all screwed up and he'd say,
what is wrong with this guy?
Oh,
he's shooting the whole time instead of looking around.
And then just from one iteration and the big differences when you're not doing
the I add when you're actually watching it unfold,
everything becomes,
so we,
this is like when I talk about detaching your,
this is my earliest or some of my earlier experiences of being detached as
you're watching these immediate action drills unfold.
And I remember one officer that was all jacked up and I watched him like,
why is it,
why can't this squad do a whatever?
Why can't this squad do a,
uh,
a strong left or whatever or appeal,
right?
Why can't they do it?
What is wrong?
So I'm watching this one officer and the other officer like,
well,
this officer did it fine.
I watched him,
the contact happens and that people start shooting.
And then the guy looks around and mixed call.
I watched this other officer,
the contact happens,
he starts shooting and he doesn't stop shooting and no one's making the call.
And it was just as simple as like,
hey man,
your job is not to shoot.
Your job is to make me look around and make a call that you learned so much when
you're instructing,
not only because you have to think about what you say and you have to be able to
articulate why.
And that makes you dig deep into the reason why.
And then you get to detach and actually watch it unfold and watch these little
minor mistakes happen.
And then you get to correct them.
And then you get to recognize them in yourself when you make them.
It's a powerful thing too.
And I,
when I was at trade it,
I think we did a good job of transfer cause no one had,
you know,
it used to be [inaudible] to go to trading.
I don't want to go to training.
I don't want to go to trade it.
I think we did a good job of transferring the mentality to,
hey,
if you want to get good at this job,
you got to come here.
You got to.
Yeah.
Which I believe is the truth.
So anyone,
if you want to get good at something,
just try and teach it.
Same thing with Jujitsu as well.
The uh,
um,
that was an sop for us when,
when I was in land warfare at five was when the guy was having a hard time.
We'd pull them up.
There's like,
hey,
come stand next to me,
the RSO and just watch your guys 80% of the time.
That would,
that would all fix the problem.
Yeah.
Which is a testament to just attachment.
Yeah,
it is.
It is a testament to detachment in man.
Once you learn how to detach,
even though you're in the situation,
it's like just makes life so much easier.
So much easier.
Okay,
so now what you do another platoon.
So I got three platoons under my belt.
I'm working in,
in uh,
land warfare or at at trade,
you know,
training self,
the team.
And then one of the platoons that was on the Arg,
they were going to pull into Somalia and help the morale or the UN pullout a
Somalia,
this is [inaudible] 95.
And one of their,
their sniper in their platoon got thrown in jail and Hong Kong and it was a big
international incident,
so they were down a sniper.
So I happen to be on quarter deck watch when the OIC of the platoon called back
to the team and said,
we need another sniper out here.
We're down one.
And we know we're going to go into Somalia in like three months.
And uh,
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm a sniper anima sniper instructor send me.
So I pass it back to the expo and they're actually a couple,
there was another guy that was senior to me.
He was an e six at the time that was going to go.
And then something came up at the last second.
He couldn't go.
So they're like,
hey,
you're going.
So I packed up my stuff.
Um,
they flew me over to Bahrain,
the,
when the ship pulled in,
I met up with the platoon and then got in the platoon and uh,
about six weeks later we wound up in Somalia.
So I just got lucky,
you know,
because you can't,
you can't chase it.
And then in the 90s,
there was no,
like at that point,
I think there had been two other platoons that had cycled through Somalia and,
and both of them had had gotten in troops in contact,
which was a dream for all of us.
Uh,
and,
and timing wise,
this is like two years after the Big Black Hawk down thing happened there.
So gotten that platoon,
um,
another arc platoon back on the same ship that I did in my first argument.
We were in the same burning space.
What ship was it?
The Ogden,
they'll be d five.
Uh,
and uh,
but another guy that was really another guy that was a big mentor of mine,
I looked up to a lot was,
and he was,
the Lpo is Monte tree size and money had been around as w for a long time.
And he had the additional deal where he'd,
he had broken service.
So he was a police officer up in Los Angeles.
And,
uh,
he had a lot of,
you know,
because those guys where he'd actually been in gunfights before and in high
stress situations.
So it was,
it was really good having him,
having them there.
And then when we did go ashore,
myself and the other snipe,
we split up into two different sniper elements.
And Monte was with my element.
And then the,
uh,
the other sniper was with the,
the chief was with him and then they each have,
it's bad like five guys in our group because it was an excuse to get a shore.
And the reason,
and this was completely the marines deal,
they were there to pull the UN out,
but they didn't have the 50 caliber sniper rifle capability.
And that's something that they wanted to have so that they could reach out these
long distance and be a little bit more surgical with,
uh,
their application of force,
um,
smarter.
So we wrote,
our officers were able to sell it and uh,
and then we got to go ashore doing that.
And that was,
uh,
how many,
how many days did you spend on the ground,
man?
We were only in there for like three days.
And so the Marines,
I think we were on the,
the second lift to shore and I was down on the airfield,
but the airfield in the Mogadishu airports right up against the ocean.
And,
and it's
the reason I say is because before this,
or maybe it was after this,
but I was cutting gator squares,
which means driving around in circles off the coast of Somalia for,
for a long time.
And we were supposed to go in and we were,
we,
we add,
we got our issue of,
of Ammo,
real ammo,
you know,
all of our gear,
our ammo,
our mags were loaded.
Um,
are,
I remember I put the real,
um,
40 Mike Mike into my vest for the first time and they didn't quite fit right in,
like it was a no one and no one had ever done it or no,
like I didn't know.
And,
and so here we were and we,
and so we did all kinds of maps.
We were ready to go in and then we,
we never went in,
which was,
and part of the reason we didn't go in as the same reason we didn't go into
Rwanda because Black Hawk down had happened and people were just like,
they were,
everyone was super hyper cautious about everything.
And so yeah,
I remember we were going,
we were actually taking boats into the airfield.
That's what we're gonna do.
So I remember that of your field being close then.
So,
uh,
this is a funny cause you guys flying in helicopters.
Yeah,
no,
he wrote it on one of the big hovercraft,
the elk act.
Yeah.
But we went in,
so,
okay,
this is not dangerous now,
but you know,
the Mogadishu airports are controlled by the UN and then there's that green
beach right there,
which is infested with bull sharks.
I think there were like 12 total shark attacks and a couple of fatalities on
that beach.
So we got tasked with doing the hydrographic recognizance.
There's some story about some kind of slaughter house or something that I never
saw it,
but that was the story where there's a camel slaughterhouse and it just teeming
with blood and there's sharks can't resist.
That's exactly what we are going in with.
We had that story,
the big story,
like the midget sniper in Iraq
and they're all,
they're all just waiting for you to hit the water,
you know,
which is kind of what I think anytime I'm doing anything at night,
it was like in,
in the ocean.
You're like,
like the sharks are just waiting right there for you to come in and just come up
and bite you.
I'm so stupid.
I never think about that.
I never one time in my whole career thought,
okay,
I'm getting in the water.
It's night in southern California.
There's big sharks live here and there could be one.
I never thought about that for whatever reason.
I don't know.
I am too.
I do.
But then I'm like,
oh,
I'm cold now and I think about something else.
So you're,
so you guys take oak accents.
So wait.
So we go to do a hydro recon and,
and because of the sharks we got to do this big perpendicular hydro recon,
perpendicular,
parallel,
whatever.
Um,
and we're doing it with Zodiacs and then were spaced every 50 yards and then the
ribs on the outside of it.
And the water is,
I mean,
so he is not swimming.
We're not,
you're taking your cousin from boats and on,
there was a big net that we had to get out of there so that the elk acts,
Noi,
handcraft come in.
So I'm in the first rib and then an a rib is a,
like an inflatable,
whole 30 feet.
And then the next one out is,
uh,
like 50 yards,
past marks.
So the water super clear,
like you can see the bottom and it's like 60 feet deep.
And,
uh,
the boat out past me,
they're all yelling.
They're like,
hey,
look down there,
some sharks down there.
So one of this,
the team guy that was in that boat jumps up on the sponsor of the rib to look at
the sharks and slips in the water.
And it was like,
he hit a trampoline.
I don't know how he did it because that the river so high out of the water,
you're like,
how did he even get it?
But he got in and he was out so fast.
I'm not even sure he got wet.
Oh.
And I don't blame them,
but no,
we went in,
uh,
there was just,
the planning cycle was crazy for that four days.
Everybody was down to the spot they were going to be in.
We didn't,
our study,
there was a bunker that we wanted to use,
um,
that would be a good position from where we were at.
So we run like the third lift on the elk [inaudible] those big hovercraft,
but you can't sit down on the deck.
So they had this big 40 foot mill van strapped to the deck.
You went inside of it and then there was a bunch of troops seeding and then we
just rode in on that hope the thing didn't sink because you would just be done
God out and then patrolled over to our spot where we,
we wanted to set up in this,
this bunker.
And uh,
it didn't work.
The slits out of the bunker,
the scope of my 50 cal would stick out and the scope was looking right at the
cement.
So then we built,
we got up on top of the bunker and we started filling sandbags,
moving sandbags around.
Made ourselves a little like firing position on top of that bunker and uh,
um,
and that's where we send our cover down on your covering down,
looking for attackers on the,
came into to try and attack the airfield.
So the air field was controlled.
So we had set a perimeter up inside of the UN perimeter that was already there.
And so the first day there,
nothing really happened cause it was all status quo.
The UN controlled the airfield,
there were watchtowers and stuff like that.
And then we had a line set up that was just a narrow strip of beach,
um,
between us and the ocean.
So when the UN left and we would just all fall back into the amphibs and go back
out to the,
to the ships.
So the first day,
you know,
there's always tracer fire going on in Mogadishu is pretty active.
Um,
not much happened.
Then the next morning at like 4:00 AM all the manned positions were replaced by
tanks and then everybody left and they just,
there was a big camp,
like 500 yards to the south of us and they just,
uh,
they just,
they just left everything there.
And then,
then at like eight in the morning,
the tanks all left and just left it open.
So there was this weird period of time where everyone was like,
what just happened?
And then a lot of the civilian populace started piling in because there was
like,
there's water,
there's building materials.
They were ripping the roofing,
awful lot of the buildings at that,
these guys that just abandoned.
Um,
and then about an hour after that,
the,
you know,
you had your different uh,
um,
warlords and factions figured out what was going on and then they had to stop
people from getting stuff cause they wanted it.
So we watched like a big crowd of people and it was just like in that movie,
there's a big crowd of people ripping stuff,
running everywhere,
ripping stuff out of these buildings.
And then guys show up with a jeep.
Would like a PKM,
which is a belt fed machine gun in the back and just aim at the people and start
shooting them and then you just see it like oil and water,
whatever.
Everyone moved and they're just all taking off.
So one clan kind of took control of a camp that was at 500 yards of the south
end of the runway there.
Five,
600 yards away from us was the edge of that camp that was you and controlled the
other clan,
which these two major faction as a warlords down there control the other end of
the runway.
At one point they move down the runway and tried to attack this other clan that
was holding because you can't control half of a runway.
And they had like this crate,
they had crazy technicals and are our rules engagement,
let's hey,
they can have technicals out and that's a civilian vehicle.
It's like a road warrior vehicle with some kind of crew crew serve weapon in the
back.
And they had one was like a big five ton truck with a clod antiaircraft guns sit
in the back where the dialect,
you know,
dialing the thing to move it around and stuff.
And they went halfway down the runway.
They tried to shoot it out,
but the,
this other camp,
the other factions shot back and shot them off of there.
So that went on.
But that was really those two fat.
There were some spillover tortoise,
but was as two factions shooting at each other.
Well,
at some point people start,
they started the one faction that controlled the south,
this camp to the south end of the runway started to shoot at us.
And so we started taking a lot of indiscriminate small arms fire.
And then we had a,
uh,
a recoilless rifle launched at us,
but it went over and landed in the ocean and some random RPGs.
It was all pretty far away.
So you know,
as you know,
in an urban environment,
it's,
it's really difficult to tell where you're getting shot at.
And then,
especially when they're 600 yards away,
there's,
it's daylight.
You can't see any muzzle flash.
So unless somebody gets really sloppy or you're really lucky,
you're not going to see it.
And the way Mogadishu is like a big hillside with all these buildings and rolls
up,
it's just not like you're looking at one set of buildings.
You're looking at like a row billings,
then behind it,
another old buildings and yeah,
just a giant,
giant mouse maze.
So,
um,
saw a guy on a roof with an RPG and then a second later one gets launched at us
and then we're like,
oh,
okay buddy mist.
And then,
uh,
so we basically,
at that point they're like,
you're,
you're cleared hot.
This is silly.
We've met our rules of engagement cause and then
back in the 90s,
the appetite for applying lethal force was,
was pretty subdued.
It's not as liberal as it is today and how it should be.
And so it took us a little while to get there and they're like,
okay,
these guys are bad,
these guys are obviously trying to get us.
So you're cleared hot.
Find somebody to shoot Dana and couldn't find anyone to shoot for a while.
Then this camp that was 500 yards of south of us,
we saw it was a group of like seven guys,
two of them had RPGs.
Your rocket propelled grenades and other guys patrolling with like two Pq,
two PKM gunners,
their belt fed machine guns and like an AK gunner and they're patrolling and we
can see and we can see them.
And now they come out the front of the camp and at the gate of that camp,
which is facing us 500 yards away,
there's two sandbagged positions for the watches who would be up there to check
people coming in and out.
And they,
the guy,
there was one guy,
he had a gray.
Ironically,
he had a gray t shirt on that said army,
right?
And he's got an RPG and he's definitely in charge.
And he put a p Cam on one of the sandbags pointing us,
he's talking to guys given direction,
turns around,
puts the the RPG on his shoulder and is looking at us through the site.
And so are our,
oh,
I see is like,
okay,
well,
hey,
let's hold on,
see what we're doing.
The money.
Whose money is really savvy,
he's like,
hey,
they're getting ready to shoot at us.
He's adjusting the sites right now.
He's getting an,
and we wanted to preempt this so I could shoot it.
The guy before he got a chance to launch CRPC cause they're close.
That's a good plan.
So,
um,
oh,
I see.
He's like,
okay,
go shoot him.
So I've got kind of a,
I've got a really jacked up firing position.
It's a 500 yard shot.
I uh,
I squeeze,
squeeze around off boom.
And then apparently I missed.
So,
which,
which I,
my,
my shooting position was not good and I was really,
really like excited.
I that what they call,
you know,
buck fever.
It's a first time I've ever saw it at a human.
So I was worked up pretty good.
Um,
and then the guy who was spotting for me,
it wasn't a spotter because there was,
the sniper was in the other platoon or at the other,
the other firing position.
He was sitting right next to me on the sandbags,
looking through the spotting scope.
And when the 50 cal went off,
it's got a big muzzle brake,
so the recoil doesn't break a collarbone,
it ports back.
It just blew a bunch of sand in his eyes and knock the spotting scope right out
of his hands.
So money's like,
Hey,
you missed.
I'm like,
do you have a correction?
And,
and he's like,
no.
And it sounded like he was talking in slow motion because he was just just super
calm and cool and uh,
um,
I'm like,
oh no.
Now I'm questioning whether I,
my,
my dope,
my dad on previous gay for five fit 500 yards is any good or anything that 50
cal you to take the entire bolt out of the gun,
knock the brass out from the round.
You just fired,
put a new round in,
chamber it and reload.
So I chamber hit reload downrange.
They were,
they were like,
Ooh,
they just shot at us,
you know.
So the guy was like,
wow.
So they're starting to talk and now he's got that RPG on his shoulder and now
our whole little harder.
I take a breath,
let half out,
start to squeeze that trigger.
I get that surprise bake,
boom,
pull the bolt out,
knocking the brass out,
load another round.
And I'm going,
did I hit?
And our comms guy had grabbed by nose and he goes,
oh man.
And I'm like,
did I hit end?
He goes,
God,
Garnett,
good grief.
And I'm thinking that he's going to tell me that I missed by like half a mile
and he doesn't even know what kind of correction to give me.
And I hit him in the arm.
I'm like,
dude,
what happened?
Did I hit any good?
And he didn't even hear me.
He goes,
he is.
Oh,
that had to hurt.
So now that PKM gunner who,
who was set up on the sandbags,
he just lets her rip.
And so there's the,
the,
the bullwhip crap.
So those rounds going over the top of us and man,
he's like,
Hey,
I think this guy's right,
right at 500 yards.
You got,
you're dialed in.
You know,
he's just talking in my ear like,
man,
like we're going to get the mail or something or,
or whatever.
Just calm.
And then,
uh,
so I can't see the guy at all.
All I can see as the muzzle flash.
So I put the cross hairs in the middle of the muzzle flash,
squeeze the round off,
reload,
come back up and look to see what,
what had happened.
And there was uh,
the gun had spilled over the front side of the sandbags.
There was a huge divot in the sand.
I couldn't see,
I couldn't tell,
I think I hit the rifle,
but then he had spilled out,
he was out from the side of the sandbags on his side and,
and it's just,
his guts were everywhere.
He was flailing around for a little bit and then he expired I assume cause I
quit looking at him at that point because a jeep had now shown up and it had
like one of their 50,
51 cows in the back and the guy is just new go boom,
boom,
boom.
And I'm thinking,
Oh man,
we've grabbed the tiger by the tail cause I've got this round,
I can,
you know,
one round at a time.
And I'm waiting for like there was a tow missile gunner right in your position
for him to light it up.
But uh,
we'd gotten really,
really strict rules of engagement briefings before we went in.
So the guys were a little bit hesitant to let her rip.
So that shot,
I rushed,
I wound up hitting the jeep
right on the sidewalls between the gunners legs.
But that was enough.
Soon as the jeep got hit,
boom,
they drove away and they were done.
And then these guys started to do a peel and it was a really organized squared
away.
Good peels.
So they were peeling behind the buildings of the,
now they are starting to gain a little bit of distance on us and they were
falling behind this big building.
[inaudible]
has given me,
gives me another round.
He's like,
Hey,
I think there are about 700 yards now adjust your dope.
So I.
Dot.
Made my adjustment from,
from where I was just shooting at to to 700 and as you know,
as the,
they're doing appeal,
a guy gets up and runs.
So there was a guy I've run in full value and he's running across with,
with the Rock Rpg.
So I shot at him,
hit way behind him and he went behind the building,
then reloaded two more guys peeled behind the building and they were just gone.
So I held,
I held my cross hairs on the edge of that building where they had just gone in a
second later,
the guy with the RPG steps back out into my crosshairs.
And so my cross hairs are squared up on his pelvis and I start loading the
trigger as he's taken a knee to shoot the RPG.
So his heat knee hit the ground when that 50 cal round hit him in the chest.
And so we were shooting,
uh,
the,
Ralph asked mark to 11,
which is a multipurpose armor piercing around and it explodes when it hit
something hard.
And the spotters like,
Bro,
that thing right up when it hit his chest
down,
he went.
And then,
uh,
then that was it.
Then they got some guys over there that,
uh,
linguists and they had loud speakers on their Humvees and they were like,
Hey,
don't shoot at us.
We're not taking sides in this whole thing.
And that kind of calmed everything down for the next couple hours,
um,
and end of that day,
and then we watched the guide.
It's like life was incredibly cheap there.
Saw a guy get pushed off a roof.
We're watching,
uh,
um,
in the evening we had gotten,
someone said like,
Hey,
this one building about two kilometers away,
that's when the clan leaders buildings and we could see guys up there in the
evening and they get that cop there that makes them all go kind of crazy.
And we'd see guys sitting there like watching the sunset up on a roof and then
one of them would start to get animated and waving their arms around.
Like they were arguing about something.
Then they're all animated.
Then they were up like beating each other with clubs,
hitting each other with rocks.
And then it would just stop and then it would start up again.
And I think at least one of those we've watched the guy just get pushed off a
roof,
fall dead.
That's just how they roll.
And so this,
so the first day was pretty mellow with this.
All this activity took place on the second or the third day.
First Day was mellow,
second day was a owes when they pulled back.
And then the third days when they said no,
the first day was metal.
Second morning is when they pulled back.
And then the second day is when we got in that first firefight.
And then it was either that afternoon or the next day,
my memory,
you know,
it's been 13 years,
Emory slips where they called and they had,
they had an issue with the guy.
They're like,
Hey,
what are three years?
But yeah,
we'll take it.
Okay,
I should have taken more disciplined.
Um,
they,
uh,
they hit us up.
They're like,
Hey,
we've got a guy down here that is close to where we're getting ready to move
some armor and he has an 84,
which is weird because that's one of our weapons.
It wasn't an RPG hit.
He had a legit 84 and they shot at him and he ran away and came back.
They were like,
he's going to use it.
So we want to do this deal.
We're going to have a sniper initiated kind of assault on this guy.
So I'm
listen an l e v over to our position,
me and the,
Oh,
I see God in it.
And we went and saw the the lieutenant colonel and he's like,
Hey,
I'm here.
We studied a map.
He's like,
Hey,
here's where the guy is.
I think a good spot is this tower.
There's some recon guys up there.
I'm going to put you up there with them and then then get this going.
So
I went up to the tower,
we moved up to the tower.
The guy showed us what it was,
was out there.
There was a set of bunkers,
it's alongside of the airfield that was now controlled by just whoever.
And this guy was in one of the bunkers.
And then he would come out with like six or seven other guys and you in a,
you know,
and they would smoke cigarettes and he had the 84 and he would,
they were watching the u s lines.
So they said,
hey,
here's what we want you to do.
Um,
you know,
he keeps coming in and out when he comes out again,
we want you to shoot him and then we're going to have,
they shifted some of the light armored vehicles down the line to where they
could go at,
go at the bunker with their co-ax guns and try and get him and his buddies.
Um,
so we put us up in the tower.
There's this like 20 mile an hour wind,
just howling full value.
It's a right to left.
And then it's from where I was in the tower,
it's a thousand yard shot.
So,
so I got a bunch of sandbags bunkered my position up.
We waited around,
you know,
for the guy to come up.
He comes up.
So I take this thousand yard shot at a guy in a 20 mile an hour,
you know,
full value crosswind,
which at the time there's probably two or three people in the world that can
make a shot like that and I'm not.
One of them.
I missed and hit his buddy.
So I didn't hit the guy with the 84.
I hit the guy with the AK 47 Stan in three feet to his right because I put in
too much wind and they all dove in the bunkers.
Then everybody on the line started shooting the bunkers toward the bunkers up.
They called the ceasefire and the one of those guys survived and it was the guy
that had that 84,
but he left it and he just got up and ran away.
Um,
then at a later point there was a guys they were shooting at the ELC acts as
they were coming in and out.
And so we,
we s there was a,
there was a big cinder block wall,
seven a hundred yards away away from the,
uh,
um,
the airfield there.
And he was on the other side of it and there's one block missing and he would
look through and shoot through it.
So I shot at him and hit the wall right next to the,
where he was shooting at and I scared him away and then come back.
But uh,
then that was it.
Then the next day we packed up and everybody fell back out to the ship.
The marines ran a great operation because everything kind of went like
clockwork.
Exactly the way it was supposed to.
And it was a good to go.
Then you went back on elk acts,
you just said the either Yell Cox came up on the beach back in the mill van God
back in the middle of and went back out to the ship.
And then the final deal was there was just a strip of the amphibs that just
drove out to sea as they broke down the final deal.
And that was it.
Yeah.
That was,
but,
but then I was like one of six guys at the time on the west coast that had,
you know,
been on the trigger.
And,
and been in combat.
Yeah,
no,
I remember it was awesome.
I was super stoked and super jealous.
Of course.
Like every other guy was like,
which actually this isn't why I did another arc because it seemed like,
hey,
if you're going to get some action,
you need to go with the Marine Corps in the Arg and go out and do that.
That's why myself and all the other guys that,
you know,
all my old running mates,
we all were like,
okay,
we'll just do another arc.
Get back over there.
Let's,
let's make this APP.
Let's go into the problem.
I mean,
I had two dogs and two cats.
My action ribbons.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
it worked out for a lot of other guys since then or before that because there
were two.
The other guys that had rotated through Somalia,
had been on art platoon.
When you get home,
you know what was going on.
Were you married at this point?
I was.
I was married to my son's mother.
And,
uh,
and when did you get married?
I don't remember.
Was it,
was it?
No,
but not,
not what year,
but like what have been trading cell at the time was in training cells time I
was at two.
You're pretty much a f uh,
less than a year of marriage or maybe two years of marriage at this point.
And then how,
how is that dealing with,
you know,
being gone and being the team guy marriage,
which is generally really hard.
It was hard.
And it,
I want to back up really quick cause I want to make sure I point this out before
we get into this next thing.
And another thing that that Mani [inaudible] taught me that we kind of talked
about a little bit was he's like wherever you go run for mayor and he's just
talking about be good to everyone everywhere you go because they're going to go
out of their way to take care of you.
So like the,
that crew on the organ,
on that deployment,
they took great care of us because he always went out of his way to be good to
everybody.
You know,
just to go back to Monte a little bit,
it's weird to think about
now,
right?
You look back at what you did now,
what you've done since then,
which is obviously a ton,
and going back to you being there.
And when I think about it in my mind about how just,
uh,
I guess immature is part of the word,
but it's beyond just being immature because I'm not just talking about being
immature and the traditional sense of the word I'm talking about being combat
immature,
meaning no one had any combat.
Right.
And I think about just having a guy like Moni who's like levelheaded,
who's been in some shit before and can go,
you know what?
Hey,
we need to shoot this guy before he shoots at us.
That's just totally sensible thing to say.
But if,
if everyone's,
because you've got these massive roe briefs and everyone's being paranoid and
you can't,
hey listen,
we don't want,
we don't want this to escalate.
And all of these things are in everyone's head.
Yup.
And it's so easy.
It's kind of like the detachment when you just go,
hey,
you know what?
This guy has an RPG,
they just shot one at us.
He's aiming it and he's going to shoot us again.
We need to kill this guy.
Okay,
go ahead.
And then instead of,
you know,
dude,
you're low,
you know,
or whatever,
just hey,
you're good.
Load another round.
Just being calm.
When I think about the advantage and how that's a pretty good performance,
what you guys was a pretty good performance with no experience because I think
of how,
you know,
what I gained through experience and the maturity,
the combat maturity of seeing things and things unfolding and being like,
okay,
I can handle this right now or this isn't a big deal or whatever.
But man,
when you're,
when you don't have that,
everyone's all excited that everyone's freaking out and everything's just
magnified and so it's pretty impressive.
And it,
to me,
you know,
again,
you have a guy like money that's just looking at the OIC,
his boss and saying,
Hey,
we actually need to kill this guy right now and not be like,
well,
you need to take this guy out,
which just escalate.
Then the OIC is thinking,
oh my God,
you know,
he might say,
shut up,
you know,
whatever.
Just going,
hey man,
we need to take this guy out.
Just just having that mentality is,
is so important and I dunno how well would you guys have done if he wasn't
there?
I don't think we'd done as well and we,
we might not even been in the position where we shot.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah cause he just carried us through that whole thing.
He,
he,
he had a funny thing he taught us.
He goes,
if you're ever really excited,
and he may have put this out to you too,
over the radio.
He goes,
if you try to talk like you have a southern drawl,
it'll slow you down.
And he goes,
and you won't have a southern draw by the way,
but it will slow you down.
And he told us of a case.
There was a,
some officers in a high speed chase and they were so calm over the radio.
People didn't believe that they were in a high speed chase except for the Rep.
The speed at which they're gone out.
We just pass this street.
We just passed this street.
We just passed this street because they were cool as cucumber commerce.
You know,
they're not freaking out.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
That's definitely just,
it's cool to hear that story.
And you've probably told me that story 21 years ago or something like that and I
actually heard you brief that story to a bunch of people at a dog and pony show
and uh,
it was really epic to hear you tell that story.
But d to hear the full,
actually younger,
do you ever give you that detailed of a debrief?
But it's awesome that at that time,
no combat experience.
It's like,
okay,
here's what we're going to do and that's a good lesson for everyone,
man.
Detached,
stay calm,
look at what's going on.
And it all does.
Go back to the fact that you were in that position,
probably had something to do with the fact that you,
that you,
you were running for
mayor or,
or you know,
Mani as a platoon chief was running for mayor and building relationships and
hanging out with the marines and teaching them whatever and getting,
giving them some gear and what,
you know,
just doing those things that you're building relationships with the rest of the
team is of being an arrogant jerk to everyone because you think you're better
than him.
Absolutely.
Cause there was another unit that had 50 cal sniper rifles that didn't get to
come.
Well,
there you go.
There it is.
Okay.
So now you get back.
And how long was that deployment?
Was that just a six month or a wool?
They,
they were already deployed,
so I didn't look three and a half months with them cause I replaced it.
Got a guy that got in trouble.
Got It.
And then,
but okay.
So now we were starting to dive into a marital scenario that was going on.
So you've got a kid already,
you've got a kid.
Uh,
my son's mother was pregnant when I went on that deployment and so he was,
that was in February and he was born in September of [inaudible] 95 truck.
So yeah,
I came back and then it was one of those situations where,
um,
me being gone all the time didn't help but me being home all the time didn't
help either and it and,
and so we just parted ways and it,
it was,
uh,
it was hard for me not to have my son in my house,
but it was,
it was the best thing because me and his mom just didn't get along.
Um,
and then this is at the point,
at the same time,
this is this,
when you got out,
this is ripe with it.
Art,
we got divorced right after I got out.
Which did you get out with the vision in mind that you're going to be able to
save this thing or did you get out with it in your mind like,
no,
this is already too far south.
No.
Yeah,
I got out.
She,
she wanted to like,
Hey,
I want you around more.
You're gone too much.
Is,
you know,
this isn't good and get that.
But then so you got out,
I got out and then she realized that she really doesn't like,
yeah,
pretty much and I can't blame her.
So,
so then then we ended up separating or,
or get,
you know,
going through the new land,
getting out,
oh I was going to go work for a guide doing some kind of uh,
um,
investment stuff.
Cause that makes a lot of sense to
me.
There was no plan.
It wasn't thought through.
The smartest thing I did was the date.
The day I got out,
I enlisted in the or or I joined the reserves.
So I was in the seal team,
five reserve teams.
So I did that for a year and a half.
And then when all the dust settled and uh,
with,
with uh,
the,
you know,
who's going to have custody and where my son's going to live,
it was like,
what am I doing?
I'm only happy when I go to do my reserve drill.
And so I'm like,
Hey,
I want to go back on active duty.
At the time,
they were critically under man for East sixes.
So they're like boom.
So the timing,
my timing,
I've been so lucky for my timing,
like being on the quarter back that one day I checked into trade at in August of
2001 into the sniper cell.
And then you know the planes hit the towers and then the teams are just off to
the races.
Yeah.
Did you,
when you,
when you were civilian,
um,
or whatever you were a reservist,
civilian,
how long did it take you to realize that this was a bad call and I'm going to
jump forward.
Like when you would have guys that were saying they were going to get out at 13
years or nine years or whatever.
Did you,
what'd you tell him about that?
Oh,
you mean later?
Yeah,
like later.
Like,
cause you know,
I would,
you know,
when I was,
well,
you know,
once I was an officer and I would have friends that were like,
Hey,
I'm going to get out.
And you know,
I'd say the experience I had was I went to college.
Right.
And when I went to college for three years and when I came back I was like,
the main thing I learned in college was never,
ever,
ever get out of the team's ever.
Because dealing with other people,
it was just so horrible.
And especially,
I mean like you and me who literally spent our whole adult lives in a platoon
you get out of in the know with normal people and you're like,
what are the everyone doing once I have w why is this even happening?
It just nothing makes sense.
Yeah,
there was a lot of awkward silences.
No one gets your jokes.
And it was a,
what I usually tell guys is like,
Hey,
I got broken service and you're going,
once you get out,
you're going to miss this peer group,
you'll miss this job and I don't think you're gonna make that much more money.
And,
but I never,
I always tried to soft sell hay and I w I would tell guys,
here's my phone number.
Do not lose my phone number.
And if you decide you want to come back and please call me,
I will,
you know,
figuring out how to get you wherever I'm at or back in and a,
and a,
and I've done that for at least two or three guys.
Yeah,
no,
it's a,
I know it's a hard decision for guys to make and it usually,
and sometimes it's um,
what does that,
it's an emotional decision completely because they had a bad deployment,
they didn't like someone or their wife's mad at or whatever.
And they make that emotional decision when in fact the teams can take care of
you too.
You know,
the teams can go,
hey look,
we know you need some downtime.
You're going to go to buds and being an instructor or whatever,
you know,
for three years,
you can get your kid through high school or whatever.
So the teams does a good job usually of taking care of,
of the people,
you know,
taking care of team guys.
But sometimes you know,
people,
they have the grasses screener situation and again in the 90s,
okay,
we're playing,
we're training for a big game that we're not going to do.
And so there was a loss of job satisfaction there.
Yeah.
And,
and who knows where NSW,
what trajectory we were on.
Had these wars not started.
Yeah,
that's a good question.
Okay.
That's a scary question.
MMM.
So what'd you do when you got back in?
She went,
got great when went into trade at,
just got stood up and I went into the sand up.
That was 2001.
That's lucky.
Huh?
Uh Huh.
And so I got in and there they're like,
hey,
we're going to do a sniper cell and we're going to be dedicated to this,
which is something that wasn't replicated on the other coast.
Um,
I was like,
Oh man,
are you kidding me?
I'm just going to do sniper stuff all the time.
Yeah.
Throw me in that our patch.
And you were the perfect,
literally the perfect guy,
and they probably were just overjoyed to have you come in there and did it meet
world experience,
which is serious at that time because no one had it.
Yeah.
And so it allows you to say stuff to people in and they're going to listen to
you like,
like we were talking about earlier,
where if a guy tells you to get your,
get your haircut and he's a goofball and ain't done anything,
you're just like,
yeah,
whatever.
And,
and then when you're running that sniper course,
okay,
are you guys now,
was that the sniper course know the sniper course was already stood up.
So now what we're doing,
this is what we kind of ended up with that trade at,
which is you guys are going out to training,
you're implementing sniper things into the overall training and you're doing
specialized training for the snipers.
That's what you ended up.
Yeah.
So for a little bit,
we were still running the sniper course,
I think until like 2002 or three and then doing the sustainment training.
And so,
you know,
we developed a urban course,
the long range target interdiction course,
which they stay,
they have a different variant on it now.
But,
um,
you know,
that's,
uh,
the land,
it was under land warfare and the land warfare,
oh,
I see at the time was a warrant officer Pritchard,
Doug Pritchard.
He's an awesome dude.
He still works in shooting to this day.
And,
uh,
we got a lot of cool stuff done.
Like we got the,
the ballistic computers,
which made,
you know,
shooting a whole lot more predictable and then we could get guns ready to go and
a lot less rounds because we have these computers that did it.
And we did a lot of good research and development and then tactics that we could
push directly to the platoons,
which,
I mean,
NSW snipers are like the mainstay.
Hmm
[inaudible] group,
I think of,
of snipers in the world.
Yeah.
I'm not saying that we're better than anybody because everybody's really good,
but we've had really rich history of employing snipers and doing stuff with,
with snipers,
you know,
as you well know.
Yeah.
And speaking of that,
how did you end up doing an augment because you've augmented to Ramadi,
right?
Right.
And what year was at 2005 so there was,
there was some of that video that got released of a,
you know,
it's guy getting a couple snipers or whatever it was in Ramadi.
And uh,
the commodore at the time saw that and he goes,
that's it.
And they,
they had a piece of gear that was supposed to help us detect enemy snipers.
And so they bought some,
they gave it to us to test out real quick.
And then we got to take it forward with a seal team seven to go,
hey,
here's this new gear,
here's how you use it.
And uh,
and then it also gave us the ability to get,
get straight over there and kind of ended the fight.
So we team seven had just moved into the shark based there,
Ramadi.
And then we went in there with them and they,
and did you stay there for six weeks?
I wasn't awesome.
So cool.
I didn't,
I didn't want to come back.
But you know,
you come from the strand.
I didn't do the workup.
My guys didn't do the workup and there's other guys doing PSD and they're like,
hey,
what's up with these dudes who aren't even at our team and they're going out on
sniper missions so it's not cool.
It's combat tourism.
And I was super lucky that we were able to,
you know,
be there as long as we were.
And then it was just like,
ah,
it's time to go.
You did a turnover with the guys that were there.
In other words,
you taught them how to use the system and cops with them when he got to go out
and some ops with them got to go on a lot of data.
Like my favorite thing to do was go out on daytime presence patrols with the
army or the Marine Corps because that's what was so fun,
you know?
And then so we,
we could took to get embedded in a daytime presence.
It was one slide five ws,
which,
which for the planning cycle it's really easy.
It's like a gun to be approved.
No problem.
And then if you wanted to mix it up,
that's,
that's where it was happening out on the streets with the guys that are walking
around using themselves as bait.
So we would bounce between going out with the Marines and going out with the
army.
And in both cases it was awesome.
But I really have a soft spot in my heart for the Marine Corps because my dad
was a marine.
But when you're in a marine patrol,
it's like a being part of a big huge beast that's just walking down the street
waiting for someone to bump into it and then they just turn and go after it.
And were you guys setting up a bounding Overwatch's during that or were you just
going on patrol with us?
We would go on,
but so,
so the reason that we would go on patrol is so we could,
we could look for positions to put up sniper.
Overwatch is to,
and the sniper Overwatch is,
were to catch guys placing IED is out in the road.
Um,
and they'd already gotten like three or four cars.
Some guys went out on a really good op.
And you know,
a guy that we both know and they,
they got two guys who are digging in our id and then there was another couple
where they got and they were,
they were having an impact for a little bit so,
well that meant a lot to the marine corps and the army when they are losing guys
all the time to ids and then,
and you hardly ever do the IMD in placers actually get captured or killed.
So when they're getting laid out in the streets by snipers,
man,
those guys were excited about it
and in their time and then then,
then you know,
you had that whole thing going on with the populace because they be canned to
believe that every building had an American sniper in it,
which is a good segue.
That's exactly what you're denying them.
Freedom of movement.
And they got to look over their shoulders before they placed,
you know,
one,
one of those one five,
five rounds in the road.
Yeah.
So you get done with that,
how much longer after that,
but you go to team three
immediately.
I got back from that and then checked out a trade at and checked into seal team
three from my platoon chief slop.
And
that was an interesting ride.
That troop you cause.
So now I'm at seal team three almond tasking at bruiser and you're at seal team
three in your task unit.
And there's that,
that one,
there was some drama in that one.
And our factor,
I mean Lafe and I wrote about it in extreme ownership because this is the story
in extreme ownership of when the platoon,
one of the platoon commanders and the task unit commander did not,
couldn't get along.
And unfortunately they could not come to any kind of agreement of how to work
together.
In fact,
no.
The skipper said,
hey,
you guys got the weekend to figure out how to,
how are you going to deploy together?
And I think they could have come back and said,
look,
you know,
he,
he goes there,
I'll go somewhere else,
we'll,
we'll figure it out.
But they both came back in and kind of stuck to their guns,
which is no,
I don't want to work with him.
No,
And the,
the skipper fired in both actually.
Yeah.
How was crazy?
That was a horrible,
like that had been brewing for a long time.
And so just that drama is so horrible to deal with.
Like Vic when they're both good guys.
Yeah.
But it just,
this drama brewed and then there was all this crazy on certainty and you know,
who's going to get fired,
what's going to happen as a result of that.
And so,
you know,
I'm,
I'm glad to admiral made to call that he did and uh,
it,
it worked.
And then we,
the guy you took over as the t you commit.
So we are AIC went over and became the OIC.
Oh,
I AICR assistant officer in charge became the OIC of the platoon.
Um,
there is an officer,
you read a counseling Chit for real early podcast that the new task unit
commander,
the first thing he did the first day was sit down and give him a counseling.
Chet.
Yeah,
that's good leadership.
Yeah.
He's like,
Hey,
here's what you're doing wrong.
Here's what right looks like.
Laid it all out for him and uh,
and that was it.
And then he,
he was super direct,
gave us our left and rights and then we were just like,
I was like,
I remember thinking personally,
this is awesome.
Yeah,
he's strict,
but that I don't care if he,
if you tell me where my left and rights are,
especially we didn't know when that guy specialty because when you're coming in,
I've said this many times when you're coming into a situation where there's,
there's problems,
right?
Because there's definitely problems when the OIC and the task and the commander
just got fired.
There are problems.
You have to come in and kind of set down.
You have to lay down the law a little bit.
It's not like,
you know,
if I roll into a task and they're doing great and the one of the guys had a
family emergency and he had to leave and I roll in and it's like,
okay,
I'm not going to lay down the law and a bunch of guys that are doing well,
I'm going to go in there and say,
Hey,
I'm happy to be working with you guys.
And,
and then over time if there's things that need to be adjusted,
cool,
maybe they don't need to be adjusted,
but whatever.
It's different when you roll into a situation where things are not good and then
you have to lay down the law.
The other thing that's very important about what you just said is sometimes
people are,
sometimes from a leadership perspective,
you don't feel comfortable giving direction cause you're like,
well I don't really know what's going on.
And,
but it's,
it's important to think about times in your life or times in your career when
you didn't get good direction from the person you're working for and how just
you don't really know what's happening and you don't feel you don't.
You can't predict what's going to happen and so you,
you just feel kind of a little bit lost and then you think to yourself,
man,
I just wish the boss would just tell us what the hell he wants.
And so that's kind of what happened there.
The boss,
the new boss comes in and says,
Hey,
here's what's going on in,
here's what we're going to do.
Hey you guy,
that's all jacked up.
Here's what you need to improve.
And everyone,
instead of what in your mind,
you might think,
hey,
I'm going to piss everyone off if I come in and lay down the law.
You got to remember that people have been wondering what the hell is going on
for six months for a year.
They don't know who's in charge.
Everything's a disaster.
No decisions are going to make you come in and people go,
thank God.
Thank you for telling me what the hell you want.
I,
I'm tired of playing a guessing game every Monday morning about who's my boss
and what direction we're going into.
So that's,
that's an important part of remember now I am definitely,
there's a dichotomy of course,
cause you can come in and you can start barking orders and everyone just says,
well who are you?
Where'd you come from?
You to know what you're talking about.
You haven't been here,
shut up.
And of course they won't say that to you.
They'll just undermine what you're trying to do and cause all kinds of,
you know,
just,
just trying you,
serp you with whatever they can.
So that's a problem.
But what I'm saying is there is a,
uh,
a happy medium and there are times when you lean towards being,
laying down the law and there's times where you lean towards being more loose
and you got to figure out where that's going to be depending on the situation
you're diving into.
And so the advantage that the guy coming in ad was,
he'd been watching this situation for a while and I knew everybody.
So sometimes when you come somewhere new,
it's maybe just listen before you start making some major adjustments or
something like that and,
but that would have just prolonged the anchor.
All of us were feelings and he came in,
he had a big brief.
It was,
and after that I felt like someone had taken 40 pounds on in my rucksack.
Yeah,
because you finally knew where you were going,
who is in charge and what,
at least the near future meant,
which I think you get rid of what the near future you get with.
Get rid of the certainty of the near future.
You get rid of who's in charge,
you get rid of what's going to happen up and
you take all that away and you're just left uncertain.
And that's a horrible feeling.
Yeah.
Probably the worst.
Well,
yeah,
I think from a,
from a perspective of being led,
yeah.
Having no idea what's going to happen is the worst.
I,
I talk about that example of rats in a cage and how the rats on one side of the
cage,
they just get electrocuted randomly from the floor and,
but the electrocution isn't very strong.
The other side of the cage has a stronger elect,
electrocution shock,
but there's a little light that comes on that lets them know that you're about
to get shocked and rats prefer to know that they're going to get shocked even if
it's more often.
And even if it's stronger,
they just prefer to know that it's coming as opposed to be just randomly getting
shocked and you know why it's going to happen.
And that's basically where you were your task unit was because there was,
I mean it was like a public tool is like a public,
everyone kind of knew it was going on at least after about six months,
you know,
I would say after all of us being at the team for about six months,
it was readily apparent,
that's for sure.
And you guys actually,
the,
one of the pieces of collateral damage of that was Mike Cirelli and Mike
Cirelli.
He,
he,
they didn't know what to do with him because I forget what the internal
conflict,
but there was internal conflict with Mike Cirelli and meaning that,
I don't even know what it was,
but,
so they said,
Hey Jocko,
you want this guy?
And I'm like,
affirmative.
And then you came up to me and I was like,
Eh,
you know this guy?
And you're like,
yes,
he's awesome.
And I was like,
cool.
And then there was other people that were saying,
oh,
he's this and he's that.
And of course the other people,
I'm like,
okay.
And I listened to him and then it was like thinking,
okay,
well that's why I think I asked you like,
Hey,
what's this guy's deal like?
He's awesome.
You're,
you're stoked.
And I was like,
cool,
good to go.
Yeah.
And,
and he was awesome.
He's obviously,
he still is.
Awesome.
And then you guys,
did that work up and
then you guys deployed over two while I was in Ramadi,
you guys were over in,
uh,
in Guam.
Yeah.
So I tell you what if it,
if it hadn't been contracted,
it was an amazing deployment.
Like we,
nobody got in trouble.
We did a lot of great stuff,
which,
which is a big problem in Guam guys just getting in trouble and uh,
you know,
the,
the problem was it was,
you guys were hearing in real time like,
hey,
they just got the first Carl Gustaf kills in Ramadi and Hey,
this is happening.
And,
and I remember one day we were in were in Thailand on an exercise of staying in
a five star hotel and guys are all Columbia and I,
I didn't get everybody at the side of the pool at the five star hotel.
And I'm like,
listen,
I want to be there too.
It's not going to happen.
We have to put the mission first.
Our mission is to be here and this is an amazing experience.
I guarantee you're going to remember for the rest of your life.
You guys got to stop whining,
stop worrying about it.
And of course,
guys always joke about the fact that when you're sitting in a sweaty Overwatch
position that it's 118 degrees,
they're like,
okay,
we just spent a week in Thailand right now.
By the way.
I know.
And then when they used to do that rip yeah.
Where you'd go to Iraq and then halfway through come back to Guam.
The problem isn't Guam.
They'd be like,
guys would get back here and they wouldn't want to do any work.
Um,
and they weren't,
they weren't focused on what was going on,
you know,
but then that's the mission has got to come first.
And the mission isn't always something that you can tell stories about.
But Hey,
I got to ride elephants.
I got to sit on a crocodile's back.
Uh,
I got great per diem of
the,
neither of those.
I was gay.
It was interesting too,
like going back to the workup,
it was a good contrast for my,
especially for my officers to kind of see,
like I'd be watching this unfold and you know,
I had stoner and leaf and I'd be,
you know,
we would talk about and be like,
Bro,
this is what's going on fellas.
Look at this,
look what's happening here.
And it was a good contrast for them to see because it made it so obvious,
like why you have to work together.
Why these relationships we have inside the task and are so important why we
need,
if you have an issue,
you bring it up,
you bring it to me.
Why it's not going to freak me out.
Why we're going to talk about it.
Why,
you know,
Lafe always says,
and stone would have told you the same thing if lay fought like,
hey,
I'd like to try this a different way.
I'd be like,
cool,
how would you want to try it?
Go,
let's,
let's make it happen.
I don't care.
I don't,
I don't care what happens as long as it makes us win.
So that was a really cool for me.
Uh,
unfortunately it was not cool for you to be in a position where I could look and
use the leadership failures in that task unit.
And the other interesting thing was like,
you talk about those two guys who were like,
hey,
they're both good guys.
I've actually know both of those guys would be getting debrief to buy both of
them.
Like both of them would be telling me what the other person was doing and man,
you'd just be thinking guys,
instead of telling me,
go tell each other,
go talk to each other.
It didn't happen.
The enemies outside the wire
not owns.
Yeah.
And what were you,
what was,
what were you,
when you're looking at my task unit,
what were you thinking?
When we're in a workup and stuff,
you guys are going to go to Iraq and we're,
we're going to go to pay calm.
Hmm.
No,
that's,
yeah,
that's fine.
I mean that's,
that is,
we knew where we were laid out and how we were manned and it was all good to go.
It wasn't like we were kicking cans.
Oh No.
It's like,
okay,
well that's how it's going to be.
Well,
they propose,
they made it,
the command made a proposal that this was early on.
As a matter of fact,
I was at Niland dirt,
so that was our first block of training.
The command made a proposal that we kind of disassemble the task units and
reassemble them in a way that was more fair with regards to who's been to Iraq
and who's not.
And they made this proposal and so they made this proposal to us,
it was to me personally to that tends to task you to commanders.
As a matter of fact,
hey that we can rearrange this thing and that way guys that haven't been can get
to go.
It was like the fair fairy was coming out.
Right.
And I mean I was just like,
there's no possible way,
but I went back to Ireland and I sat down with the platoon commanders and the
platoon chiefs and the the know my senior chief.
And I was like,
Hey,
here's what they're proposing to proposing that we could disassemble these task
units and we could reassemble them.
So that guys that haven't been to Iraq can go.
And then the other guys that had been to Iraq that have combat experience and
there's all those things you can layer on top of that.
Like,
Hey,
cause guys will say,
well I can't get promoted if I haven't been to it.
You know what I mean?
Like all these things,
they layer all these things on top of it because that's a crazy proposal if you
think about it.
But also if you think about it,
that's how much it means to guys that they want to go.
And so now this is 2005 so there were still guys that had been on,
shorty do over there that we're cycling back in,
never been to combat and they missed the 2003 2004 deployments.
And they're thinking,
Hey,
this is ridiculous and it's what you talked about earlier,
job dissatisfaction.
You know,
you've been in the teams for 12 years and you and there's a big war going on and
you don't get to go.
That is the kind of thing you have to consider and think,
how can we take care of the troops,
you know,
take care of the guys because we want it.
They all want to go to war and there's a war going on and yet we're going to
send them some of them to,
not war.
But I came,
I came back in Ireland,
I was said,
hey guys,
here's the proposals I recommend.
We,
we,
they also offered,
it's a competition,
it's a competition.
And it was really just a competition between my task unit and your task unit
because the other task unit,
they,
they actually didn't,
that task unit didn't go to Iraq on the last deployment.
So they said,
look,
you guys get to go this time for sure.
And then it was between us two and they said,
we can either split up up,
I won't do that or make it a competition and the commanding officer,
we'll decide who's going to go based on performance.
And I told my guys,
I was like,
I say,
we go for performance and we do the best we can and we will probably crush
everyone and if we don't,
we don't deserve to go and we'll go do our job in Paco.
And of course all the guys were like,
hell yes.
That's what we did.
Sure.
And,
and you know,
like when I was a CMC,
a team five and I was doing my manning,
the hard fast rule was if you went to pay calm last time,
you are not going to pay calm again.
Yup.
And then so those guys could get a chance.
And then some of the,
some of the guys that went to Centcom went back.
But in the end,
when I'm building seal leaders,
I need guys that have been everywhere.
I need guys that have had the pay calm experience and understand they're mature
enough to go all the mission is first.
And then guys that had been exposed to combat so they know what that's all
about.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and when you got done,
so when you got done with that platoon chief Torque then where'd you go?
So,
because I didn't,
because I was in PE calm,
I,
I made a deal with the new command master chief and I said,
hey,
I know I'm stepping down but I want to go to Centcom.
So can I stay here in the capacity of,
as,
as the OPS chief for one troop,
which was the,
and my,
the guy who was the OIC of my platoon who fleet Jack Riggins fleeted up to be
the,
uh,
um,
the troop commander.
And I'm like,
Hey,
can I,
can I stay and go to Centcom now?
Cause he was going to go to Centcom as his,
uh,
his,
his ops chief and they're like,
sure.
And it's,
I'm actually stepping down.
Tony did the same thing.
Yeah.
And then Tony and I both made senior chief and they're like,
hey,
it's time for you to go home.
He's Eh,
and uh,
they sent us over to the senior enlisted academy and then we went over to seal
team seven to color,
which worked out
great.
We won't get into that later.
And you know what w w the great part that you just mentioned is like a three
hour conversation,
which we don't,
aren't going to have right now because look the second part of your career or
the part that if,
yeah,
we'll get into this.
We'll do another one.
We'll just,
we'll just roll,
do another podcast.
We'll record it like tomorrow.
Um,
and that's going to follow you into Afghanistan.
Back to Iraq again.
More time,
more training,
more tours,
combat tours,
tours as senior enlisted tours as the command master chief towards as an ops
master chief.
I mean,
there's a lot of massive
stuff to talk about from here on out.
So we'll do that.
We'll record that tomorrow.
Good
check.
Um,
Echo.
Yes.
While we're waiting for the next podcast,
I know,
have you probably have some suggestions on what we can do instead of just
sitting around and waiting?
There's probably some ways that we could get better.
Yes,
I do.
How do you have for the nations?
First thing is Jujitsu.
Jason Jujitsu.
Yes.
One stripe white belt.
He goes so and so we know.
And what,
what did,
what did it feel like when you got the bug?
When did you get on the map for the first time?
Legitimately thinking.
All right,
I want to know what this is all about.
Okay.
So the,
the same master chief that taught us and go on.
Oh,
Steve Bailey,
Steve Bailey.
I trained with him for a little bit in Guam and then just got distracted.
I dug my teeth into a little bit,
but then,
uh,
like a year ago I started training out and he's counting.
Yeah.
And uh,
it was just awesome,
but I was like a spazz and so does death match.
It's like,
what am I supposed to like relax?
I'm like,
why am I just supposed to lose only right now the 49,
49.
So everybody that asks,
I'm 51 can I started Jujitsu?
I'm 39.
Can I start to do to whatever age you are?
The answer is yes.
You can start to Jitsu.
We recommend that you calm down when you start drinking.
What's your real,
I wanted to roll with you.
What's your relaxed relaxation level right now?
If I was,
cause I haven't read in like six months,
be I probably spazz out for a hot minute and then figure it out.
But uh,
yeah,
because you're torn,
you don't know what you're doing,
but you just don't want to roll over and like,
Oh,
here I have my arm.
Yeah.
Right.
So you just hang on to that triangle and uh,
know that it's a,
it's a,
it's easy situation.
It's a sweet situation that unfolds,
that you know,
is going to unfold,
that you know
is not the correct thing to do and there's no way you can stop yourself from
doing it.
Like you just said,
you're someone's gonna arm lock you,
you know what's going to happen.
You could just go,
okay,
you know what,
um,
I'm just,
he's got me,
I'm going to let them.
But no,
you cannot stop yourself from guerrilla gripping your other hand and a hanging
on for dear life for an extra 12 seconds before you tap.
There's no possible way to overcome that.
It's just common.
So yeah,
you have to do that,
but hopefully you can make through that.
You can make it through that transition fairly quickly.
Yeah,
it was amazing for my kids to all kids.
It's a beautiful thing.
It's a beautiful thing for kids.
Yeah,
it seems like the spasming thing,
even as you get it,
I mean obviously the,
it happens less and less,
but there'll be like momentary spazz situations even at like the top level where
you kind of got to stay calm.
I mean,
every once in a while I'll run into it where I got to stay conscious of it.
Like,
oh,
I see the danger coming and it's coming pretty quick.
You got to think,
well I and my sister,
I'll think through it and I'll be way more successful rather than like,
oh spazz through it.
So now I'm more tired and it's still coming kind of thing.
I hate to say this too because it's horrible for me to put this out there,
but there are times when you have to spazz to escape something.
Dean lister will,
if I do that,
he just like,
he,
it's worth it.
Even if I get out,
it's worth it that I spazzed cause it,
it can make fun of me.
Oh good defense pass.
He's just making fun of me because we know we both know.
The only reason that I got out of whatever he just did to me is because I kicked
and squirmed in spazzed out and he wasn't ready for it.
And then I got out.
Yeah,
the next one,
oh well it'll work out,
but a huge cost.
So there's like tooth,
this tooth,
little additional elements to a successful spazz escape or whatever.
One you gotta be at least somewhat strong.
Like you can't like a,
a smaller person,
like spasming is less effective.
Even at a high level.
There's that.
And then when you're strong,
when you're a strong person and you spazz successfully,
you're way more tired and more tired.
So you get a person in where you put them in a spasming state like two,
three,
three times in a row.
Yeah,
no more.
Oh yeah.
You can't spend more than,
don't think you have a Mac spazz reps of foot after that year,
the next one,
there will be no spots left.
Yes.
Three legit spazzes that there's no done with spies left.
And which brings you back to went back early on as a white belt or something
like this where you know it's spazz fas,
fas and they feel the effects of three spasms in a row hate you and you're like,
Dang,
this is exhausting when you start,
that's judges too as just spazzy Morris Bazzy and then it's like the opposite of
when,
you know,
in the beginning there's these small moments where you don't spass yeah.
And then when you get better,
there's small moments when you do spazz and then when you're really good,
I mean very seldom do I make dean spazz.
Yeah,
I do.
Occasionally though it gets a little,
little,
little crazy.
And you know,
I in a,
in a way to where that's why these smaller guys,
when they're super advanced,
I don't think they have response ever.
[inaudible] been unproductive for them.
Every attempted spazz is going to be like unsuccessful,
you know,
and,
and it,
it's a spectrum obviously.
So their whole thing is just thinking through the thing.
Andy Burke,
sure he does this,
his form of Spazz is like this silent spazz he pretends it's not happening.
But it is happening.
Covert camel class.
He's doing these like in little movements and it's,
there's only one technique that it could truly be called.
That's a spazz,
but he acts like it wasn't.
He's real cool.
He's acting like that was just like a defense that he knows.
I'm on to you,
Andy Burke.
I know what's up.
That's a good tip.
I want to look out for it.
I don't know if I've ever made Andy Spazz,
but you know I'm going to be looking out for it nonetheless.
When you're in Jujitsu,
we all need a geek.
If we're doing gete and I'm not saying you have to do,
you should do.
I think.
Yeah,
she recommended.
Yeah.
Do both.
That's the recommended boat.
If you trained Geeky Nogi both.
Oh yeah.
The place we were training at.
They did both.
Yeah.
So one night was no gay.
The other night was g was awesome origin gies.
They're awesome.
Oh,
interesting.
So you're already in the game.
So some people,
they may or may not be looking,
hey,
what kind of,
Gee should I get?
There you go.
Just like daisy Gardner said,
forging Geek hundred percent best factually by the lacing gardener with the
origin g plug,
common straight off the top ropes.
He just pulled that out of nowhere.
He's like,
you've got a trache and Nokia.
And by the way,
I have happened in the origin gate,
which is the finest g in America.
And many people say the finest in the world.
I say that.
I said that too.
And it is made in America by the way.
Um,
so yeah.
Anyway,
when you get,
you go to origin main.com,
that's where you get it.
You can also get other stuff like rash guards.
Sure.
Gnocchi.
Yeah.
Uh,
if your name is Echo Charles,
no,
I shouldn't say that.
If your name is not Jocko Willink,
you can get joggers because I don't look like normal.
I don't,
I don't know what to say.
I look,
you don't match.
I don't,
I don't feel match joggers or not for me.
Is it a,
what is that?
But you just don't match.
So here,
this is what actually,
this is what it is.
Okay.
Jogger INA with joggers are pretty skinny.
Yeah,
they're so their skinny jeans,
sweatpants kind of tapered.
We're not kind of,
they're really tapered little bit of a,
what do you call it,
like a drop crotch.
A little bit for like a lot of Rumi in the hips area kind of thing.
If you think they're functional.
Yes.
But I think the big push is a style thing.
Cause there's like skinny jeans and all this stuff.
So it's kind of like a functional thing.
Yes.
But it's a style thing.
That's the part you don't match with any,
especially anything that says skinny or thin or trim fit or what bro,
that's not you.
That's somebody else.
So yeah,
that's not going to mess with you at all.
In fact,
even to,
you know,
people have like real fitted jeans does.
Yes.
Like real fitted tight.
I'm not gonna say that say fitted to,
you should not do that either because that's not,
it's just not you.
But the weird thing is the world changes.
Right?
The fashion changes.
I just keep wearing the same stuff.
Yeah.
At some point is what I were going to come back.
We'll fashion wise maybe,
but maybe not what I wear.
This is the thing,
I think what I wear doesn't,
it doesn't say,
hey,
you can't say,
Hey,
this guy's wearing a tee shirt and a pair of jeans.
You could wear a tee shirt and a pair of jeans in 95019601970 never,
never go out of style.
Never goes out of style and actually even to to be more precise since years.
You don't go for fashion at all.
You go for like this functionality kind of situation.
So if,
if anything you do is like fashion,
which I know we have a real problem,
the fashion stuff in your past,
like maybe hairstyles,
et cetera.
That's why if you see old pictures of the Jocko with his hair,
you'd be like,
they'll be like,
ah,
I,
you know,
this kind of the thing that's the,
that's the guy that Jason was talking about earlier.
That's me.
Like we will like that.
Like,
Hey,
we were in the teams were hammered it home hair,
cool.
Push the envelope as long as I could get it and know the fashion thing to look
good.
But your clothing wise,
you'll never go fashion.
So you'll never go out of style because since the fashion of the thing that
revolves and goes out of style,
origin,
jeans,
uh,
I got like the final kind of cut and everything,
you know,
they're legit.
So that's another thing there.
It's not fun.
It's not a fashion thing.
Right.
Their origin jeans,
well,
they're not mutually exclusive either.
So functionality are strong,
they're flexible,
they're durable,
they don't go to stuff that stuff's not going on a style and sure it's not.
So there we go.
Origin genes.
We're are in production with origin genes in production at this time.
So check the website,
origin main.com if you want to get some jeans or if your name is not Jocko
Willink,
you can get pair of joggers.
The joggers are good.
That's the thing where I,
I wasn't done for the joggers.
Pete told me this,
he opened my eyes open,
my little like mind or whatever I put them on.
I was like,
Dang,
these are comfortable.
But man,
they're skinny.
They're thin,
you know,
they're,
they're tight.
They had a specific look that I wasn't very accustomed to but,
and Pete's noticed it.
He was like,
yeah,
they're like,
you know you gotta he's like Jocko that they're probably not for Jocko,
but you pull them off.
That's what Pete said to me.
Oh Man,
I hope he was like being like honest with it.
But yeah.
Ever since then I was like,
okay,
maybe I can do this.
So it only warm at camp.
So it was like,
oh,
I might not wear these at home,
but when I'm at Camp and then at Camp I was like,
Dang,
these are good too.
And when you jog they're way better than regular sweatpants.
And I'm like,
oh,
these are good.
And they're like super comfortable too because you know the cotton that they use
or whatever.
And then I'd where I'm at home and that's all I would wear now.
I kind of switched over to that whole thing to for real,
hey man,
how are your pockets?
Are the pockets,
all kinds of life changing things happen on this podcast?
One of them is Echo Charles switching to joggers be noted.
We pockets.
Like what for like functionality or like for my everyday carry.
So I'm going down to the store and the joggers.
Yeah,
I would say like any other sort of sweatpants situation.
Hidden pockets on either side,
right?
Like no regular sweatpants.
Don't have pockets bro.
All the kind you're talking about.
I'm talking about,
you know like the SGM coach from 1979 they're not done.
They have pockets for sure.
I got to tell you,
I saw those boots online and I'm pretty excited.
Right.
I opened the gun mentioning that now we're,
we're making them,
we're making them and yeah,
they're awesome.
You have a pair of those too.
Hey Man,
you got your one,
your one like one degree separation from getting all the new stuff to where
you're at really.
Cause it feels like one 80 and you know,
I'm over here to looking online at stuff anyway.
Also Moke Moke train Jason,
we talked to her earlier.
Recipe morning recipe.
Okay.
So I get up in the morning,
brew 20 ounces of coffee.
I grind up the beans,
do it in the French Press.
I add a little bit of Stevia to sweeten it,
but it's not going to spike my insulin.
Then I put some coconut milk in.
There were no coconut oil,
grass fed butter,
about a tablespoon is at some MCT oil,
a scoop of vanilla milk.
I hit that with a stick blender or did that little hit her.
I do not have to eat until like one or two in the afternoon.
I get all my fat in early in the morning so I ain't gotta stress getting good
fat in and that's it.
That's awesome.
That's an advanced take.
Are the kids on the block chain?
They are and uh,
is it,
have you tried strawberry milk and strawberry warrior kids strawberry?
No,
we haven't.
We've been doing the chocolate hot chocolate.
Yeah,
the hot chocolates.
Awesome.
I didn't know iris has been making the pancakes.
Oh yeah,
she's just using it and mixing straight up pancakes because axel was talking
about it the other day.
There was a guy in London who was like,
yeah,
more pancakes.
I was like,
techniques,
a good idea.
So it just added them.
I basically replaced like us portion,
a percentage of the pancake mix with milk.
Do it.
I don't know what pancakes are even made of because I haven't had them in so
long.
It's just raw.
Hey Bro,
that's on you and you're kind of missing out on that one cause it did.
They work out really good.
Yeah,
we're on that.
We're on mint.
I'm on mint and I'm actually in this whole deal now when I'm having both men,
peanut butter,
I don't really,
I don't really like the flavor of Vanilla as I've mentioned on here so I don't
have that.
But the strawberry to the warrior kids,
strawberry milk,
which Brian is working on the adult strawberry milk,
the vanilla,
like I'm not a big vanilla plan either,
but it just mixes so well.
Yeah.
So like when Iris is making smoothies,
the vanilla milk in there,
I put it in my coffee because of the mint chocolate chip doesn't work
cause it's my favorite like okay I get to have dessert and that's exactly what
it is.
It scratches that itch when it comes along.
See that's the thing,
man.
I went out last night,
I had a legit stake,
legit at Raglan ob and I still was needed a little something.
I need a little something because they sell this thing at Ragland called the
illegal,
which is a giant chocolate chip cookie cooked in a cast iron thing.
It's massive in the nave put vanilla ice cream on it,
which is the only time I like vanilla and the vanilla ice cream is all melting
is just ridiculous.
But obviously that's not part of Graham.
So I left Raglan ob without eating an illegal and I went home and I'm like,
I still need some kind of a little hitter.
So I went peanut butter and went peanut butter milk and I just did.
I did it like a scoop and a half with a half of Shaker of water.
I drink that thing.
It was so good.
I was sitting there saying,
this is a milkshake.
If this is a milkshake,
it's freaking ridiculous there.
Yes sir.
And the added protein,
this stuff,
forget that for the end and don't forget the probiotic.
Remember that microbiome.
It's true.
Yeah.
We haven't even gotten to your whole health scenario cause what'd you say?
You're 50 years old.
51 49,
49,
49 50 this year.
And you're getting after it.
I feel great.
You feel awesome walking around at like one 57 and in before I had,
you know,
before I adjusted my diet and everything else,
one 93 and they had all kinds of inflammation and everything hurt just crappy
and now it's all just dialed in.
Yeah.
I remember when you were first going down that path because our wives were
hiking and you and I met somewhere and we were just talking about like you were
starting down this path and you were coming home from deployment
to doesn't do it for you.
This is my last deployment.
I don't have deployments to go on and get back in shape,
so I'm going to have to stick with it.
And um,
yeah.
So those supplements,
joint warfare twice a day,
two in the morning and two in the evening that the turmeric is amazing.
Yup.
Krill oil in the morning every morning.
And then usually,
uh,
anytime I'm going to do something that disciplined go,
yeah.
Jp said the other day
when he took the discipline go,
he could,
he could see people's thoughts
anyways,
pick,
get all this stuff@aoriginmain.com sorry,
just taking a really long time.
It's all good.
And also Jack was the door.
It's called Jocko store.
So Jocko store.com me and,
and uh,
yeah,
they say if you want to represent discipline equals freedom.
This is where you can get you shirts,
hoodies,
hats,
trucker hats,
flex fit,
flex man.
I can go either way,
but within,
yes.
Fence,
Walker,
no,
both sides.
Right.
What do you call it when you can adapt and adjust one?
Either way bill and it's got to have a role in it though.
I'm not a flat bill box.
Yeah.
That's actually strange coming from a California person because that's like in
the last couple of decades or something.
That was not,
yeah,
check either way.
There you go.
Jocko store.
That's where you can get them.
Or sorry,
Jacqueline,
store.com I'm also women's stuff on there as well.
Yeah.
If you want to represent while on the path,
that's where you go.
It's good.
Also Jocko white tea.
If you're dead lifting and you're like tired of your like 500 pound deadlift,
tired recharge,
which yeah,
I can see how you'd be tired of that and you want it to go up to 8,000 pounds
Jocko white tea and it happens to tastes good and it happens to be USD organic
certified organic organic.
Yes.
That's a good one.
Now that adds a kind of a little spin because people used to say to me,
did you ever picture that you'd be making tea?
And,
and it's kind of funny,
you know,
and I'd be like,
yeah,
whatever.
But now it's like next level.
Did you ever picture that you'd be making organic tea?
That is kind of a different thing were in it.
Maybe I'll be wearing joggers soon as the whole world going crazy if you don't
subscribe to this podcast,
which is shocking to me.
But now we have reports from the field of people that listened to 167 podcasts
and haven't subscribed to it.
And so now echo has made it clear that you need to subscribe.
Also,
don't forget about the,
the warrior kid podcast.
You were on the warrior king podcasts.
Ted's kids.
Have the kids memorized them yet?
They love it.
I mean,
pretty much I been lagging.
I don't get them out as much as I can.
Part of it is because I liked really like doing those stories from Uncle Jake
and they take a little bit more time and so I'm need to invest the time,
the cute,
I should just do the Q and A's as well.
But anyways,
warrior kid podcast,
if you want to get your kid on the pot on the path
and what you,
what you and I were talking about earlier of how your kids just don't really
want to listen to you.
They listen to Uncle Jake.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Just listen to uncle Jake.
Absolutely.
I had an another master chief,
uh,
east coast master chief come out and came to the gym and he's like,
Bro.
And I never,
I didn't know,
you know,
he's just like another guy.
He's coast guard that I didn't know.
And he's
like,
he's like,
Bro,
your book,
your little warrior kid books.
He said,
you got my kid,
he's 11 years old.
Everything I did for 11 years to get them to do pushups and pull ups failed.
He goes,
he read that book.
I,
he's like,
I can't thank you because it's awesome.
And I was like,
Dang,
it's 100% true.
If you're,
your kids are not going to listen to you as much as you want them to,
they will listen to uncle Jake for some reason.
Uncle Jake,
we'll,
we'll take it home for him.
I listened to Uncle Jake.
I love those books.
Yeah,
I'm taking them just reading the books.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I got to fix that.
Oh,
here's something I could do better.
Yeah,
true.
It's,
it's,
yeah,
it's uncle Jake.
Uncle Jake is who uncle Jake has good information.
He's kind of everybody's uncle Jake
and people,
people will say like,
oh,
aren't you know your Uncle Jake to me?
And I'm like,
I am so not uncle Jake.
If I was uncle Jake,
I'd be so much cooler.
Well,
Jake is my legit,
I'm just a little warrior kid over here and trying to turn a learn to try to get
on the path.
That's the way it is.
And where your kid soap,
you can get that.
Irish oce,
Irish oaks,
ranch.com.
Speaking of warrior kids,
Aiden's making soap on his farm and he wants you to stay clean.
What about one of my kids said today,
uh,
like comment and subscribe.
I was like,
oh my God,
wait,
who said that?
Just one of my kids were,
I don't know what we're talking about something you don't own.
Some Instagram,
this and that.
And then one of my kids is like light comment and sort of subscribe and
subscribe that's going up there.
If I start saying that you get the joggers out,
we're already making organic key for some reason,
which is just crazy.
That's a good thing.
It's just you.
I know it.
This tastes good and it's good for you.
So these are all things they just sound kind of lighthearted compared to your,
you know,
your whole anyway also.
Yes,
Youtube.
By the way,
that's where they stayed.
That's where you can run into these videos.
Where this,
cause my daughter,
sometimes we'll watch a little youtube videos and that's what they'll say,
like comment and subscribe,
just repetitive there programming,
programming the children,
they get it.
They get it.
Oh yeah.
So Jackson,
I can say that,
but we do have a youtube channel and you're basically right now saying subscribe
to the Youtube Channel and so want,
Jason says you should like the youtube channel.
You should like it.
And then I'm over here saying you should comment like comment,
subscribe.
Here's the thing.
I don't know that you can like the youtube channel video,
which is up quote unquote like,
but here's the thing,
you liked the youtube channel.
He liked the youtube channel.
That's a matter of opinion,
right?
Yeah.
You like it,
you kind of neutral or you don't like it kind of thing.
That's up to you if tell you to like it.
If you want to have fun,
you can go to the Youtube Channel Jocko podcast and you can look at the people
that attack the down votes.
So there'll be no,
we don't have many downvotes which is I guess cool.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Or whatever it thumbs down.
People get mad.
They get mad.
Goodness of Isis terrorist.
Just gate.
Who?
The 13 isis members that gave this a down vote.
You will rot email.
So thanks for having my back there.
They also liked that.
Liked it.
Let everyone know that echo looks jacked,
Echo,
look to whatever.
There's a video that was just released.
Um,
what's the most recent video you just did that just got normal face?
Normal face reaction.
One overreaction.
You released the video.
You are not in the video but people were saying that they could feel that you
were jack just from watching Tiffany.
So call it goes jack psychological warfare.
You can get that on iTunes,
Google play,
MP,
three platforms.
You think you might have a moment of weakness when your day to day life press
play and you'll get pushed through that moment of weakness.
But Jocko by the one by me,
we'll say spotted.
That's better.
Yeah.
Because some people,
they're not in the mood to get pushed.
Pragmatically reasoned with.
Yes.
Adequate reason where he could also speak in a reason.
When you want to improve your home gym,
I dunno,
maybe even your commercial gym,
you're 24 fitness Cottonelle but on att.com/jocko get yourself more kettle bells
like me got the storm trooper trooper one by the way.
Oh,
you're going to break out some star wars nerd stuff over here bro.
Yeah,
you ready?
So Jenga fat was the guy that they used for,
they're like,
oh,
you're the perfect warrior.
We're going to make all the clones based on you.
And I believe that his deal he made with those people,
it's like you're going to give me one of the clones back then I'm going to raise
as my son who turned out to be bubble fat.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wait,
wait.
So you're taking your letting me know because I messed that up.
I think Jane,
yeah.
Tune you up.
And then on the last podcast,
if you guys are talking about it again,
is there,
is there books for that?
Because you're more positive.
Nerd Jason.
Oh Hey.
I played dungeons and dragons when I was in high school.
So yes.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I can be open about it today.
I was horrified to tell you when I was in high school and dragons or that gone
out right now.
Like I don't care.
She yelled and you got all kinds of you.
You got all kinds of like little nerd.
Uh,
no science fiction.
Nerdism right?
Yeah.
Hey,
enjoy science fiction.
It's a lot of fun.
There you go.
That's cool.
We're up.
My younger brother who's a tattoo artist up in San Clemente,
he has a complete storm trooper costume.
Do you got the data by the way?
Are you in the five Oh is it the five oh first Vader's fist?
No.
Well mine is.
I got the storm trooper costume.
Like what's five oh first Vader's fist.
There's an award or something.
Yeah,
there's an organization that does a lot of
just like work for like going to see cancer kids and stuff like that.
And it's all these people that are star wars villains and because they don't
make cop,
no one could make costumes cause it's all licensed.
So they have to make them themselves and then you go there and they'll validate
it and say,
okay,
you're good to go.
Your costume is good.
And then,
uh,
and I hope I'm not screwing up the unit name,
but I think it's the,
the fibo first Vader's fist.
Huh?
I've never heard of that.
That's pretty cool actually going deal one.
The one I have is like,
I don't know if it's a licensed costume or what,
but there aren't any,
you just,
it has to be so good that they're like,
they'll validate it because there's no such thing as a licensed costume.
No.
For any,
for just make this stuff somehow.
Yeah.
The ones that got sued,
we were like a lot,
they were like,
well I bought two.
There's a Darth Vader one and a storm trooper.
They were like a few thousand dollars to my brother.
$1,000 for,
well,
not just to have it though.
That's the thing.
He was spurred off for flex point.
I was making these videos,
the hobbies of Darth Vader,
I gotta go check those out.
Those are really good videos.
So,
so we use the to reach the potential on those videos.
By the way,
you didn't get,
you didn't get where you needed to get.
Well we were going,
I know the trajectory or like um,
like famous Jujitsu people like Jeff Glover Keeney corny like these guys.
Premise is we're just living our life.
But Darth Vader's here too.
So like he's doing this,
he's going on dates.
He,
you know,
he's doing this stuff anyway,
it turned out kind of funny or whatever.
So there's one where the storm trooper was in it.
He was kind of his lawyer when he got arrested at the choppy Dean's head off.
It was pretty good.
Yeah,
it's deep thumbs up.
He's like tricky.
He's like the ex boyfriend of his date or whatever.
So it's a theater like chops his head off.
So the next episode he gets arrested for that and then his lawyers a storm
trooper.
So that's why I love it.
Yeah.
Do you ever see that one where they did like a cops episode but it was troopers
and they're storm troopers and they show up to Luke's aunt and uncle and it's
really a domestic dispute and they kill everybody
know
it's old,
but yeah,
there's a lot of fun to be had with those guys for sure.
And then last I got the kettle bell and it got it from on it and they got some
good stuff on there.
[inaudible] dot com that's,
yeah,
good spot including star wars stuff.
I also got some books,
Mikey and the Dragon,
Mike in the dragons.
Jason,
you were actually maybe the third or fourth person to hear me read Mikey and the
dragons and I did it on the beach in corn auto to you and iris.
I was so excited.
I couldn't believe it.
When you started rhyming and the whole thing kind of like how did you do that?
It's like he's still rhyming and it's still going in.
This story is just awesome.
I'm super
stoked on Mikey and the dragons.
It's how old are your kids?
Eight and six and what age group can it go down to,
would you say?
I'd say probably three.
Yeah,
it can get young.
It's got very beautiful pictures that are bright and colorful.
There's so,
yeah.
And then the story rhymes.
It's going to make your kid smarter.
And there's times where I was when I was writing it,
you know,
they say right at a certain level,
but at the same time I put some words in there that kids aren't going to
necessarily know right away.
And so they need to look them up and they need to learn them.
Polies is one of them.
I remember using the word poison.
I was thinking,
well,
most kids won't know what poises and then I thought to myself,
good,
now they can learn a new word.
Be Smarter.
Yeah,
that's a good point though.
When you say where does it go down to?
So three,
I would say they're my sons like to,
he was like just before two and a half and I'd read it more reading it to my
daughter.
He's there,
but he'll catch certain things.
You know when there's like monsters ready to bite,
he'll be,
you know,
like he'll know certain stuff.
So as you kind of get older you absorb more and more.
But yeah,
if you're too,
it looks for them too.
There you go.
All kids.
If your kids are a little bit older,
you can get in way of the warrior kid.
You can get Mark's mission,
which is the second book in that series.
And now we have booked three coming out.
The title of book three is where there's a will and mark gets involved in some
more situations.
But luckily his uncle Jake is there to help them out.
I get so many pictures of kids doing pull ups,
working out,
studying.
They're going to be a warrior kids.
So get that book for your kids,
get that book for Your Library,
get that book for your school,
get that book for anyone that you know that has kids,
you'll be thankful and they will be thankful and they'll come and thank you in.
You know,
it's cool going to wrestling tournaments.
Yeah,
this is pretty cool.
I've had kids that are,
you know,
freshmen in high school,
so they're 14 years old or whatever and they're like,
Hey,
I read while your kid.
That's why I wrestled.
Yeah,
yeah.
Think about that.
So three years ago when it came out,
that kid got it and now he's wrestling.
That's what I'm talking about.
Get your kids that kids will listen.
Uncle Jake,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
If you want to know how to get after it.
There you go.
You have to wonder.
You can just get the field manual if you want the audio.
It's on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
and we're going to be the path lives.
I'm sure it's true.
Extreme ownership.
First Book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin
and then that follow on book is the dichotomy of leadership,
which is
takes all those lessons and shows where you can screw them up and then teaches
you how to fix them.
Dichotomy,
leadership,
both those books,
me and life.
We wrote them,
check them out,
and then we have echelon front leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
It's me,
it's Leif Babin.
It's JP Denelle.
It's Dave Burke.
It's Flint Cochran.
It's Mike's Really.
It's Mike [inaudible] and it is now also Jason Gardner.
Jason is at Echelon Front.
He just retired and this is what we are doing.
He's already got gigs booked,
which is awesome.
Echelon front.com if you need help with leadership in your organization,
we will help you.
That's what we do.
We have the muster in 2019
2124 may in Chicago,
1920 September in Denver,
four and five December in Sydney,
Australia.
Every event we've done is sold out.
Go to extreme ownership.com if you want to come,
otherwise it's going to be sold out and you won't be able to come and you'll be
all mad and you'd be mad at me.
And then someone said that,
it's like when I went to Lollapalooza and I went and saw a Rollins who I kind of
knew and I was like,
hey man,
can you get us in?
And Rollins said it'd be easier to sneak you into Fort Knox.
And I kind of like was all hardcore,
like you kind of forgot what it's like in the streets.
But it wasn't up to him exactly.
Now,
now I'm the guy.
Now I'm the guy that's going to be saying,
hey,
be easier to sneak you in a Fort Knox.
I gave you a heads up.
You're big time now.
So check.
That's that.
If online online interactive training
from echelon front we needed to speak to more people and we don't have enough
instructors,
couldn't run enough monsters each year.
So if you want to know what we teach,
you want to get granular with it.
Check out f online.com
and finally we have the ETF Overwatch,
which is where we take guys that came from special operations and combat
aviation.
They have massive amounts of experience,
leadership experience.
They understand the principles we talk about,
we write about that we teach,
they understand those and they will bring them into your company.
You can hire them to work and help your organization
when
for overwatch.com is where you can make that happen and if you want to keep this
conversation going,
which is a pretty varied conversation where we're talking about star wars and
said sniper operations that are joggers in d and d.
I mean that's pretty good spectrum.
You know you might be that d and d old school d and d player with your
multi-sided dice getting after it and if you want to talk to us about that.
We are on the interwebs.
We're on Twitter,
we are on Instagram,
we are on the phone.
He bought echo was adequate.
Charles,
I am at jockowillink.
Jason is at Jason,
n Gardner,
Jason and Gardner and on a Facebook.
Jason Dot.
N.
Dot.
Gardner on Instagram and Jason and okay.
Gardner on Twitter.
And you're new to all three platforms?
No,
I've been on Instagram and Facebook for awhile.
Okay.
You're just new to Twitter,
new to Twitter.
Have you ever checked out Twitter before?
No.
It's mayhem and then I heard I'm going to have to be careful.
No,
no,
I heard no,
don't like you do have to be careful.
Yeah.
And you kind of don't.
But it's weird.
But then I found out like they were talking about,
uh,
maybe with Sam Harris and he was talking about deer.
There's legitimate,
there's Russian people,
Russian bots.
It sounds so funny.
They're sitting,
they're just trolling.
They're just trying to create mayhem.
And so we don't have a lot of man to be quite honest with you.
There's not a lot of mayhem coming at me,
but for whatever reason.
But everyone's pretty cool and it's,
it's,
I've gotten a lot out of it.
Out of Twitter,
out of Instagram,
out of Facebook,
people giving me information,
recommending books.
I'm,
I'm the book recommendations because I'm pretty much exhausting my personal
knowledge of books right now.
And so right now I'm getting so many good books from troopers out there that are
letting me know what's up.
So Echo.
Anything else?
Any other star wars comment?
Well Nino for right now,
no.
But now that we know that,
you know,
we had,
Jason has a knowledge,
mm.
Maybe later.
But yes,
for now.
Thanks for,
thanks for being here.
And Jason Go.
We'll continue this conversation.
Next podcast.
Anything else?
Any closing comments?
I'm really excited to be on the podcast.
I just want to tell my wife Iris that cheese amazing and made my life so much
better by meeting her.
Um,
my oldest son chase,
how proud I am of him and a storm and for love.
You guys.
Awesome.
Looking forward to seeing you soon.
And of course,
um,
we actually could not do this podcast or even live the lives that we live if it
wasn't for or people in uniform around the world here at home.
Our military personnel,
police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics and EMT is correctional officer's border patrol.
All first responders out there.
Thank you for what you do every day so that we can do what we do every day.
And to everyone else that's listening until that next podcast,
remember that advice that Roth Guard gave Beowulf
that you should choose the eternal rewards,
not the short term ones.
Okay.
And keep it in the back of your mind
that you're piercing.
I will dim and dark and
okay.
And death will arrive to sweep you away.
So until then,
keep getting out there into the world
and getting after it.
Then until next time,
this is Jason Gardner and echo and Jocko
out.